about to lose on time you have night G
to just walk in we can't take this
matter nice 3d amazing 25 chat cards h6
but he's just in time he's sacrificing
the Queen with Brooke c7 then rookie
submitters made and we missed it and
it's checked yeah eh eh I think he
missed rook c7 Intermezzo he did
Queen takes h7 should still be good for
white look at you yeah but dude he
missed that was sick okay
still gets the win but we'll back this
thing up like juvenile and shake what
our mama gave us in this case wasn't
analysis board
and we are live with the 2019 a speed
chess championship yet again alongside
grandmaster Robert Haas international
master Danny wrench here calling the
first ever SCC doubleheader in history
we've been doing this event for a few
years but this is the first time we will
be back-to-back with two very very good
matchups yeah we've actually two
excellent matchups today and we started
off with ali riza firoozeh the young
iranian superstar he is just 16 years
old but one of the best players in the
world as you see his feet a rating is
crossed 2,700 in classical but he may be
even stronger in the rapid and blitz
segments is particularly on line blitz
it's gonna say you say he's one of the
best players in the world he's one of
the best players on chess calm for sure
if you want to talk about blitz bullet
hyper bullet this guy throws down in the
fastest time controls not something that
Levon Aronian wants to get into against
him is constant time scrambles but let's
talk about Levon Aronian and who he is
obviously he is the number one player in
Armenia one of the top human chess
players on the planet he's been around
for a very very long time and I think he
hopes to teach the youngster a thing or
two today he would love to because he
has kind of rejuvenated the country for
Armenia with respect to their great
chess culture he's led them three
Olympiad victories he has been among the
elite players for many years now he
suffered a bit in classical chess but he
takes these online events very very
seriously in fact we kind of dragged him
out of his online retirement just to
come and speech s championship yeah and
he's won World Cups he made it all the
way to the quarterfinals this year again
he's he's very very good at chess all
around and also one of the top blitz and
bullet players as you can see there his
chest calm ratings but let's bring up
the bracket remind everybody of this
matchup of course we are trying to fill
out the right side of things this week
we've got Levon Aronian sitting right
there in the number three spot all the
Reza firoozeh the number fourteen seed
although according to a lot of the fans
a lot of the community they look at all
the res as a potential favorite ooh
definitely someone who if you had to
pick an upset potential and upset
special in the first round this is
obviously a matchup that maybe maybe
brings a lot of eyeballs today as people
anticipate whether firoozeh can upset
the Armenian yeah and it's funny I see
that you know players saying actually
chatters
this is the best matchup for sure we've
two amazing matchups a of course we have
this one is starting later as you seen
the right side of the bracket the winner
of this match will play the winner of
the second head of the doubleheader and
Vladislav Artemia versus alexander shook
yeah I can't wait to see what happens in
that Russian on Russian battle but we'll
get to that of course as as we get a
little bit closer let's remind everybody
of the daily question of course we had
one to start off the week which underdog
had the best chances we're gonna find
out if the fans were correct since all
heroes AFER's are won that vote but
today's daily question use the hashtag
speed chess to get involved comes to the
community to ask them their advice on
what other ways we could spice up the
speech Chess Championship obviously the
top 12 seeds are traditionally kind of
seated by rating by invitation we send
those out to the best chess players in
the world and seat them accordingly but
we've done open qualifiers we've done
title Tuesday qualifiers right and and
what else could we do right there's
there's a lot to be discussed there you
can look at the format as it currently
stands as I said this is the seeding in
terms of how we did it this year with
both the women's and the junior speeches
championship winners getting spots I've
really enjoyed that process but what do
you think the community will say that
they can add to that format Robert yeah
I'm not sure I thought that the
selection process was great I'm sure
they all say just add more events
because they all like seeing the top
players play as many events as possible
you know some more qualifiers could be
great I'm not honestly not sure but as
we see you know I want you know me I
want to just get mad at smarter chess so
we have to talk about the match
prediction for today and of course we
see Levon Aronian as the three seed
Alireza fruit is the 14 seed that might
surprise know what what gets you mad at
mad about this I want to heal your
guys's relationship so let's talk about
this openly well if you look at that one
minute the bullet portion there to
remind ever that's one minute with a
one-second increment added with every
move played firoozeh is a hyper bullet
beast and seeing a two game predicted
advantage for aronia in that time
control does surprise mine I'm gonna be
honest with you I think even LaVon would
disagree with that with smarter jazz
prediction there the six-four advantage
for Levon Aronian
now remember the increment is the great
equalizer in terms of helping these
let's say over the board stronger
players do better in the fastest portion
right so we know that does change thing
we know that all the rezident play as
much
one minute plus one second increment and
if we look at the ranking there okay
obviously all the resident have as many
matches under his belt doesn't have as
much experience in the SCC but on chess
comm he certainly does right but that's
where that's gonna be have us on the
edge of our seats at a Robert Wright
because who knows whether those rankings
whether the power rankings and their
previous history that helps devise these
smarter chess predictions will hold true
today right and almost gonna be hard to
hold against anybody but we do have the
players seated and waited to join us
Levon Aronian with us comfortably
wearing his red Back to the Future
jacket which is ironic because Ollie
Reza is a sophisticated chess robot
clearly sent back through time to change
the future from one lucky one lucky
chess commentator this guy look at him
right there where is he coming to us
from a fighter jet just one lucky chess
commentator that hurts too that hurts
too we're here together you know we're
so close we can touch this time man
technology is really coming far that
they can visually put us together your
knowing you're in New York
yeah and I'm in Arizona and Ollie races
on a starship you know he's yes and he's
ready to rock I think we're ready to
rock the games we'll begin here in just
a moment without any further ado you I
know that the the fans are ready just
like we are the speeches championship
has officially taken off and we have won
efore oh man look at that Jaron is
carrying here Jaron his caring might
make a special sneak peek sneak peek see
it's a cameo it's a cameo I don't know
we'll see all right what do we got here
we've got a Sicilian but not the Rasta
lemo which is the popular theory a lot
of people playing these days we've got
an Italian Sicilian which is ironic
Sicilian Italian oh no idea but you know
where is out Pacino when you need it
what is your allegiance laughing you
know that's a good question I'll get
back to you but let's talk about this
structure right because interesting
you've almost got white playing exactly
the kind of moves you would see in an e4
e5 game right and we know that Levon is
an expert in these types of structures
but with the Sicilian what's gonna
change the flexibility here in the
center well you see that white has pawns
on d4 and e4 and unlike an Italian game
there's a black pawn be five so black
has control over the e5 and d5 scores
from pieces jumping there but what has
much more space in terms of the pawns
and look at
Livan just going forward with a very
natural gift I'm just rewriting his
night and here's a critical moment is
all there is is gonna play it move like
d5 and after E 5 jump his night into the
e4 square right or is he well answers
the question maintaining so this is
interesting because this is exactly the
kind of structure that would have aron
nimzowitsch rolling over in his grave
and say that white is just clearly
better right the pawns being further
advanced means they dominate more space
and with more space becomes comes more
opportunities for your pieces right if
you just count the squares available to
your pieces behind your furthest
advanced pawns that's our very literal
definition of space and chess and you
can clearly see that white has more of
it and ok that sounds very very
superficial but it but it is there's a
reason why classical chess theory
developed on hey go big or go home get a
big center and something about this
opening doesn't doesn't get me too
excited about black structure I think d5
changing it with your 94 plan is almost
a necessity at this point I think he
honestly did it at an interesting moment
because the bishop on d2 would've meant
that it didn't I got to e forward of
attack the piece yeah look at good
timing look at the vine say let's go
into a mutual isolated queen pawn
position where it looks should be
balanced right but that from b7
that might be a problematic piece
because there's nowhere for really to
operate it goes to a6 then empty
diagonal so LaVon really wants to at
some point playing with a Knight to e5
and then especially now if you put the
Bishop a6 move on the board okay one
rook e8 but still at some moment Knight
to e5
and if black takes on e5 would take with
the D pawn I no longer have an isolated
pawn your pawn on d5 could become a
target
I can make me was a queen to dthe the
reach I put my knight on a five and go
for an attack I like it and in fact as
we are analyzing 95 on our mini board
here Levon Aronian plays it shout-out to
platinum member Santo to 3 he wanted us
to share a link to guess the move and
then our moderator Tundra Mike comes
through before I even have to say
anything about it really appreciate it
if any of our mods can share a link in
terms of how to follow the games
directly on chess comm you can play
guess the move get some shoutouts
probably maybe get your username on
screen today a couple times we will give
a shout out to those playing along with
us at chess comm so Robin and I aren't
here to play along and play guess the
move we're here to make awkward puns
maybe some inappropriate jokes and learn
a thing or two
that's what Brian Boitano would do let's
do it all right queen h5 comes in to hit
seven I already like our own Ian's
position a lot here the threat of Knight
f5 coming next
okay this force is g6 but this is not
this is not a position where where
you're gonna be happy about your king
side here I don't know where the Queen
should go should I come back to free the
g4 square and maybe h6 for the night
yeah I'm a little worried off when my
queen on f3 just because the potential
tactic yeah let's look at it Queen of
three your Glock you're talking about
shake and bake with d4 but g7 is hanging
yeah and I give up b7 yeah I guess that
may be just barely pans out for why cuz
you take on c3 there and then II 5 is
hanging if you take back on c3 I can
take back with my row there's a lot of
things happening there maybe that's why
he didn't go for it in fact we can see
LaVon has put the Queen on h6
I said if you like it you better put a
queen on ya the trade the trade doesn't
mean that black gets a discover anymore
now this queen is kind of stuck here any
movement will open up the idea of an e6
clear and sacrifice followed by
something happening on g7 yeah and
actually this many three is very well
situated there because it takes away the
sea Foursquare said the rook what might
want to go to c4 and that helps try to
push d4 come over to the Kings side but
now why can't play simply work a to d1
may run to d4 well you talked about the
knight being well placed here but one of
the only other square that might be
better might be a square like d4 if you
could go to C - yep right as a routing
post you also have this funny idea of
just h3 and Knight g4 put the knight on
f6 with Shaq and then mate on g7 I'm
actually sitting here like what happens
on this so we see LaVon playing simple
moves bring the rooks to the center I
would love to play Knight g4 and then II
six alright okay but either way I was
gonna take here and get this but I mean
I know I'm probably not getting anything
but you know it is you know hey it's
something to look at as they say early
morning tactics yeah Age 3 to make chief
for a little more a little more safe for
that night yeah and we should show that
d4 doesn't work out for black because
Knight to g4 comes and the problem is
the knight f6 check of course it's a is
a big problem it's either mate or the
Queen has to give herself up so there
you go
h3
best offense is a good defense coming
from the Celtics fan there Levon Aronian
we will definitely dive into some
Celtics trivia hero on today I can tell
you that and he goes for it
I guess D 494 is the point okay so
Knight f6 would allow the Queen to sack
itself right give it up so he's gonna
have to back up 7 so your Queen h4 we
might have a perpetual you're saying no
I think that blacks taking this one
because after we niche for I just go
Bishop e7 I take away the f6 square from
young let's look at it the Queen moves
and just like that scooped off that
Bishop one c3 right and f6 is no longer
an open square oh I wonder if LaVon
missed that all the rezident kind of
bobbing his head a little bit showing
some confidence yes even Queens but
there's just there's still Knight f6 in
some weird way right yes he has that now
yeah I honestly forgot that the bishop
protected the Brooklyn you won't but
actually no no no 6 well let's analyze
it ok Knight of 6 if takes cakes and
then Pontic c3 right I think I okay
the Queen's hanging but your rook on D
was hang with check very important
Intermezzo okay crazy talk oh it doesn't
work I wanted to go for some crazy line
where I'm down everything but I'm 8u but
in the end you of Queen e5 picking up f6
very important check dirty dog
Grandmaster and if I take here you get
check you win this guy and again too
many pieces not enough time okay you may
end up getting a position like this if
indeed LaVon has blundered that might be
his best option something like that
right yeah he doesn't look thrilled yeah
he's taking a swag saying alright I let
this one slip away from me yeah the rest
I mean just played very steady defense
here this could be a huge start though I
mean we've been talking about the
storyline of these two players who will
have the better chances as the time
controls get faster and bullet a lot of
people feeling that that's firoozeh so
Levon Aronian dropping any games and
blitz yeah not a good sign for him today
yeah and we do we should give LaVon some
credit I but he scored higher than
Nakamura did and their speeches
championship match last year yeah I'm
mistaken he won the one plus one section
but at that point nothing more I had
already wrapped up the match so you know
who knows what the psychology was but
also for Allie Raisa
I think one
concerns I had in terms of his chances
was that I some must feel like he plays
offbeat lines that we get punished by a
player like Levon but here he played
very solidly maybe he was slightly worse
but never in that rough of shada and he
held his position together very well and
I think it's a matter of time now before
Levon resigns we saw him shaking his
head there we updated the moobot there
for you so you can fall Levon Aronian
not as Erie chess who was playing
yesterday mama Jarrah gave us quite the
show despite losing yep
but there you go you can click on that
link if you're in the twitch chat if
you're in the chest comm TV chat we will
share links so you can follow the games
directly and play guess the move with us
alright lavon's down a piece here so
what happened right the game got away
from maybe being a little bit too
aggressive but give the kid credit right
for being resourceful yep
defending with accurate moves and again
I think I'm just noticing the tone
setter here right I think Levon there's
plenty of time it's the longest portion
we have in an SCC format 90 minutes of 5
minute ahead but but ok this could be a
really good start for the youngster
there we remind everybody of course we
have 90 minutes of 5 minutes plus one
that means 5 minutes as the foundation
time control and then 1 second added to
the clock for a move and that three plus
one one plus one mean the same thing 60
minutes of three-minute 30 minutes of
bullet so there you go that's our time
control and a lot of people looking at
that fast time control with nerves if
you're a Levon Aronian fan that doesn't
make you happy here not at all
but I think if anyone can get their
composure and you know get their heads
together its Levon because this guy has
as I said before he's led Armenia to a
number of Olympiad victories as
underdogs right the Armenian team they
do extremely well despite being out
raided by teams like Russia the United
States yep they win their Olympiad and
that's mentioned approaches league they
be sure to you know very true and not to
mention for an individual note for Levon
Aronian the World Cup where you need
nerves of steel to win an event like
that and yet von Ronan has done so well
now he may be parting with the lady soon
unless he can get away with Queenie for
the bishop is temporarily pinned
no he just resigns decides no reason to
continue to push this one along down a
piece and not interested in continuing
so there you have it a huge win our
first shout out to our guest
movers CK 1990 gets 11 out of 25
congratulations there okay
just exciting stuff I was laughing at
chat angry chest clown wants a chest
confession to be added to the speech
amateur format we have confessionals and
some over the board tournaments where
they can take a break and say their
thoughts I like that idea being added
although his specific suggestion was so
he can confess his fence to me for my
absolution getting a little creepy angry
chess clown will talk you know go ahead
and send me a private message or don't
I'm here for a fun master mike has his
love of a perfectly placed apostrophe is
unrivaled you were complimenting my
three-year-old last night on her proper
grammar yeah delivery tonight anyway
the kind of jokes we tell in the car
today as things like in the word cent
which is silent the S or the C I let you
a lot of thriving conversation question
there you go right so that that's the
kind of stuff we get into with Robert in
town all right we're back to an Italian
this nope sorry Berlin this time we've
got Levon Aronian on the black side he
45 a Berlin with d3 maintaining the most
flexible approach Bishop d6 okay not the
most common moves an opening I've played
before and I tend not to really like my
bishop on d6 but if you see how the game
has continued it actually kind of saves
black a tempo in some lines yeah because
all the times black puts that Bishop on
c5 and then it has to retreat back to d5
pawn and as long as you get the exchange
here one of the biggest dysfunctional
points we would advise our beginner
students of never playing this move is
that it blocks your pawn which blocks
the bishop which blocks the work and the
old lady swallowed the fly so in these
cases where the pawn is traded and the
bishop is opened up you're not really
suffering in terms of your coordination
of course white still has a bit of a
small edge in these types of positions
the edge may be increasing here on the
Kings side look at this aggressive push
of the H pawn I like it I don't even
know if it's any good but I just I feel
the I feel the first genious coming from
Ferruccio yeah I would have thought
Levon was white because he's actually
become very well known for pushing his H
pawn
pretty much no matter of the opening
right white side but it makes a lot of
sense he pushed the pawn to h5 to stop
g6 and you may say how does it stop g6
well before this move Knight h4 g6 would
have been a hard
because you H takes g6 you want to take
back with the H pawn but with the rooks
tearing each other down that's a huge
problem right so Knight h4 and look what
he did he went just brought the knight
back to f3 and in the game position
because he's still trying to get this h6
g6 maneuver threatening H takes g6 and
that kind of forces g5 the biggest issue
with this sort of permanent advance is
now you've got positional access to a
square like f5 and h6 look at that move
just kind of surgically separating the
pawns right yeah I love it you're
creating long-term targets when the
pawns can't protect each other and well
the problem Knight did back to g1 so he
went Knight h4 Knight back to f3 Knight
to g1 did someone so what a knight moves
he's working on it can someone let him
know he can move other pieces I know
working on his Knight moves over there
Levon there goes another Knight
a lot of knights today 9a for hitting b
- i wonder what what you're really gonna
do when the pawn comes to b3
book ignites I don't know we really want
to invoke the Mark Wahlberg spirit this
early in the morning alright Bishop
before played look at the full board
approach from Levon right one of the
difficulties here for black everyone is
the king is never gonna have a safe
place right
there's no castle short anymore legally
and even castling long is probably never
gonna have safety so it's an interesting
decision to make
yeah and bring yourself to perhaps you
saying my king will be safe in the
center but the point you highlighted
earlier the f5 Square and that is why I
Larisa went Knight to g1 so he can bring
us an IC g3 and into f5 and rook g6 is
saying well let me try to get your age
six pawn and maybe I can castle my hand
I'll go King f8 King g8 at the right
moment and say with my rook on g6 my
King is perfectly safe yeah that's
that's really interesting although if
the Knights end up sir planting
themselves on a5 you may not be safe
even if you get there right so
Queen d4 I expect c3 not really sure
what oh wait no no there's nothing there
almost freaked out
there's no tactic so I don't understand
Queen to d7 unless this advanced I guess
helps him he's saying that d3 is now a
target yep right the pawn can never back
up he says I'm gonna push it forward Wow
look at this aggressive approach castles
long
so it's made old man the question now is
how is why can defend this pawn on d4
Knight to f5 seems pretty reasonable but
then with your knight on f5 I'll take at
least once and you'll have to take back
with a knight and then your afore pawn
feels a little iffy there yeah if I can
take on d4 bring rook to e6 or something
like that it's I know it's your boy
Kings in the center - so black team
might not look so safe but I don't think
white has the saves King either the way
you were doing there right there thought
you were about to break into like a
truffle shuffle there I don't know
what's going on here the e4 pawn the d4
pawn I think you're about to get the
line you're talking about yep you just
do have to worry about this a5 pawn
hanging because when you took on d4 the
c3 pawn no longer is there and the a5
pawn is a target in fact all heroes it
takes back so quickly with the night
makes me wonder was pawn takes a
possibility sneezing the truth there you
go hey bless you rook to e8 hitting the
e4 pawn and threatening Queen takes f5
so that's a key point that makes moves
like f3 not possible everyone because
then Queen takes f5 and he just castles
what a position this is gonna be fun
Knight 2 G 3 d4 falls but then a5 goes
with it
who's better and why I almost wanted to
ask me I almost wonder if I Brooke h4
and try to make the white King on the H
file but the knight on G 3 is very well
placed there to stop any mate he plays
King b7 quickly if is it b4 is that
Queenie entrapped almost he's all
arresting himself well there you go it
makes sense right
I guess the Queen can just go over to c5
in that case but I mean before it looks
good close you got to get the Queen out
now yet but h6 is still falling yep and
I think the a5 for white the King this
is irritating and baby me and see if I
might find Twitter f8 at the right
moment as well oh wow in fact maybe
Aronian so worried about these types of
ideas he wants to get the Queen's off
the board yeah another b3 pawn is under
attack
I wouldn't go and take it because that
opens up the B file for the F no but
that's a good point right because one of
the ways this position turns around
quickly is if black can parry the
threats and the pawns end up being week
instead of attackers then look for black
to have a very very quick advantage in
the endgame would you
you parry them retire bury them uh I go
fool perry the platypus nice and well
done I was thinking you didn't see it I
did not see that coming
I just did the quick pop culture math in
my head the only kind of math I know
for those who know Perry the Platypus
first of all you get more more credit my
book I see Jaron smiling over there
that's right if you're not a fee Gnaeus
and Ferb fan you're not welcome in my
home my kids I mean watch way too much
of that so anyway perry the platypus
world's greatest super spy look it up
it's the Quinton h8 hitting h7 but here
comes p3 you might want to take that h7
pawn I guess black can always put that
rook on h4 and try to snag the h6 pawn
mmm but oh it's check on night d3 to f4
some kind of mating attack because the B
3rd pawn you might want to capture
look at that g2 square alright but never
creates coming so you gotta be very
germane to write that King might run to
c5 let's let's get full Mahmud Jarvan
it's not even 9:00 a.m. here on the west
coast that would be awesome
I mean it's barely 7:00 a.m. what is
going on here get out to Studio C we got
Arne and Sharon Jeremy and his first
ever studio seif appearance their jewel
producers if you're gonna have to hose
you need two producers there they are
working hard um
Knight d3 coming to f4 I'd really like
this plan so what point you just take
this h7 pawn try to get a new queen
because that point is under attack you
can't capture it yeah and the H point is
far but I guess this 93 f4 stuff is you
know any moment going to be quite
annoying so he takes first on e6 Knight
takes c6 feels necessary also it brings
the knight with two the f4 potential
yeah thing is like the way to stop me
from meeting you and g2 is play F three
benefit yeah whoa why can anyone explain
that to me something about this Knight
f4 square wasn't as a tractor to Levon
as it is to us how is he not worried or
queen yeah queen Jake's age 7 or kid
well why wouldn't you take with a knight
on you 6 to come in to f4 I'm very
confused
wait you can't allow do you cambodia I
just
yeah Johnny laying me I'm just so why is
the Brooklyn H what makes does make
sense so to give a little ok puts the
brook behind the pawn and potentially
facing the king but you highlighted
earlier how perfectly placed this Knight
is right guarding the h1 square kind of
makes everything on the h-file a new
point I was thinking just ok when a 5
which you guys are both surprising us
with your hoes right now this is like
gonna be one of those super high quality
games I mean there might be a better
sign that we're not able to guess the
moves today um well he's trying to say
that if you remove your knight from C 5
say you take on b3 I get a 6 with check
and I removed your king from the
protection let's see 7 pawn and that
King on it b7 it's safe for now but if
you just start moving your pieces too
far away it could become problematic so
he keeps the night there precisely
because of that moves like a6 prevented
Queen d7 a double attack but Queen d5
would solve all things
h7 follows yeah and what's gonna happen
here right I mean it's gonna be a really
interesting finish because Queen B 5 h7
the threat is Queen g7 and h8
maybe I'll go 90 through now 4 so let's
look at it
h7 93 Queen g7 Knight f4 f3 and Queen d2
oh there's gotta be some kind of puzzle
rush where are you check I don't know
check check usually a puzzle rush I just
keep playing check still there's a good
one then I get the ex may he just he
won't be through v3 what does LaVon see
about the future here that we don't
because I is he just saying that this H
pawn is just not as strong as we think
it is I I feel like he's dropping the
ball on the potential of the mating net
counter play and if all the reza takes a
200 lead we might be proven right so
Brooke c1 here oh my gosh this isn't
work take on a 7 but the Queen before
check nice that wasn't you're still
picking up the piece but you couldn't
you couldn't take the midnight with the
Queen cuz of Queen chatter too loud
black to get a new queen with b2 which
is why I had to check first but look at
this ah exactly what I was looking for
is that pawn 17 seconds to 20 seconds
rook to b5 what a move
defending the Queen oh but if he takes
it you get a new queen up oh my god he
plundered that all heroes of shakes his
head no like in hindsight he's like oh
that was obvious what a great finish
there the Levon Aronian faith in the
b-pawn mm-hmm it's gonna take a little
bit of instant replay to back up and for
my brain to wrap my head around cause
this match is about to level itself up
with the rook coming of the h-file yeah
good night f1 because otherwise for cage
71 and they'll hold checks on e3 but oh
very nice finish that's how you do it
that's how you do it so g3 you can go g4
just to cement that pawn this place yeah
okay G fourth fret and step four but not
gonna be enough because two pawns will
be better than V 2 on it now you can
take here this is a tactic you
highlighted in our previous match you
I'm gonna back up and show exactly that
here let's bring up the analysis
boarders the net game gets underway we
will will bring that up
ooh different game trying to find that
game hold your horses everyone we've got
a lot of games going here I'll bring up
the board in just a moment yeah and
there's really fantastic finish there
for LaVon he actually handles time very
well so yeah so for that the analysis
board is showing us the end of the last
game and Robert and yesterday's match
for those of you that are true SCC fans
you've been here all week highlighted a
tactic where a lot of these end games
the key to winning the race is you
sacrifice one pawn just to put the king
on the back rank to ensure that when you
push your pawn first look at the
difference black Queens with check
preventing this pawn here so I know
where we're backing up and analyzing
blitz
despite Ezra MIDI nobs advice but though
seriously this is this is very
instructive so take note of it the
reason black wins the race is because of
the decoy sacrifice to force the king to
the first rank and a lot of times when
you're calculating pawn races if you
don't know of this idea you might miss
an opportunity to win just like this so
anyway really instructive finish and
Levon Aronian levels the score here and
wow I like it that was a fascinating
game it looked like you go either way
throughout most of we'd like lavon's
position for a while
a little bit confused by its decision to
capture on e6 with a pawn rather the
night but he held it together and he was
composed and right now with the white
pieces he's looking to get his first
lead in the match and his bishop on g2
looks quite nice in the long diagonal
yeah and well black Jimmy why is the
only one with the dark square bishop so
the Knights aren't really well
coordinated here I actually really like
White's position this early because
let's back up and see the opening I was
focused on instructing on the endgame
and I want to see how we got here cuz
LaVon can be an expert in some of these
I don't want to say obscure but offbeat
move orders in the English um okay but
Ali Reza plays the aggressive line with
e4 and this his hand is sort of forced
because the e4 pawn is now a target he
parts with the bishop pair but this f3
idea this is a really kind of typical
approach here because you're
highlighting the bishop here but the
other thing is that White has the two
pawns and eventually a big Center yep
and the semi-open F file
yeah so you can play move like efore in
the current position and just keep
pushing those pawns forward yeah d3
Knight c5 is this it's not exactly but
it reminds me a little bit of the Wesley
so Fabiano Caruana game from the
Sinquefield Cup where you and I were
analyzing that yeah and the OPA the
early open a file I know in a weird
English led to a crazy position
ultimately draw you know but it was a
fun one nonetheless um I did this one
though I mean just looks so pleasant for
white yeah you've so many different
ideas and he played Queen b6 as he said
I need to poke at the d3 pawn otherwise
you're just gonna expand and it's gonna
be a problem but rook do you wanna of
course and now Bishop f4 will come with
tempo I can decide to play for a knight
to d4 pawn to d4 I can choose how and
just optically yeah I love these pollens
right looks great black black queen g6
you might even try for f5 at some point
but okay not h4 puts the kibosh on that
idea the pony's black has to do
something to disrupt this massive pawn
Center yeah so something in the opening
theory here you know perhaps our post a
news report will be able to tell more
you and I don't necessarily have the
luxury of diving into opening theory
like we'd want you here but something
did not go well for black not at all now
Queen d6 is met by d4 so you map on e4
is protected thanks for the knight being
on h4
the bishop is open on the diagonal
here comes 'if I've to follow you this
is just a huge position this is just a
nightmare honestly for for freesia it
just seems like every single move he's
gay OD for would've met by Knight takes
d4 so he got it he at least got that
trick in that's what oh yeah I looked
okay
d4 you would have taken and then there
we have a fork yep and he for his week
so that would've been actually very nice
for black so I think LaVon overlooked
that he thought I don't know that it's
that critical I mean the night comes
depth by the tempo the Bishop to f4
could have come with tempo I still think
white is in fantastic shape here full
control completely agree it just felt
like you know moment one or two
imprecise moves all of a sudden black is
able to stabilize the position and this
Bishop on c1 needs to do something but
now if it goes to f4 that's probably
some kind of 96 maneuver just annoying
the bishop I can always go back to e3
it's not the biggest deal
look what lavon's been doing just
shuffle in the road look do you want
Rick f1 I get it I liked it from a
practical point of view you're playing
quickly enough to maintain an edge on
the clock this queen is in a bit of an
awkward spot over here I mean not a not
not a trapped situation but it just
feels like black lacks a lot of
coordination right you've got the two
knights over here but nothing really to
do against White's huge pawns the Queen
is awkward yeah it's a situation where
black would really like to induce the
move pawn to d4 yeah so you can attack
the c-4 phone that's typically worry for
yeah yeah good when these CC pawns you
want to attack one of them in this case
is hard to attack either because this
pawn in d3 is so strong and I don't
really understand exactly what he's been
doing I think I thought he's trying to
go some kind of Queen f3 or maybe you
know he's getting really tactical trying
a bit of f3 to h5 and okay who's Bishop
h3 so what do I know well no I think
that this is sort of along the lines of
what you were talking about it is a
tactical approach because what he's
doing is eyeing the e6 square h4 traps
the Queen Oh
Bishop c8 way all the rest ali reza
himself knight h4 does it traps the
queen in that h for the Queen's trap but
it might be a very interesting sacrifice
after night h4
let's look fish of H 396
I was gonna say teak here yeah you might
just take on g6 as well a couple of
pieces for the Queen this you know it's
kind of a crazy position rook f4 again
just a super patient approach from Livan
Knight age 4 is still on the board at
some point roof g4 might come in no
chief or is a threat Wow actually it's
uh that's a rook lift right there shout
out to the Berlin Airlift they're fun
master Mike nice
you didn't mention at the time but I
make mental notes anything my fun Messer
Mike baby wants my master Mike baby gets
rook F 2 so it's 95 looks interesting
yeah well thank you five is uh the
obvious response but yeah just retreat
his Bishop LaVon has been in no rush
whatsoever and he's actually up over a
minute on the clock and that's very good
news for Levon Aronian fans because you
know we sort of expected that as the
time control got shorter it would favor
a Larissa
but right now you see that Levon is well
ahead in the clock ya know and that's
that's gonna be a key point overall
right when you don't play as much online
blitz and bullet as your opponent's you
got to make the practical effort to push
yourself right don't let time become an
issue although I will say that when it
comes to anonymous accounts Levon
Aronian
knows his way around and I think he
plays sometimes more online than than
other people might know is that just a
guess I don't know just a guess sounds
like just a guess okay well the more you
know the more you know the less you
there yep yep okay after King H won I
think Bishop h3 was a possibility for
black and the reason why is if you take
a measure I take with my knight and
exactly f2 is a problem interesting and
if you take on g5 after Bishop it you
take cheat you first you take g2 for
just say F takes G five and hit the 9mh
four so I actually think the bishop H
through is a very interesting
interesting move to trade some pieces
off maybe weaken the white king okay he
doesn't go for it LaVon switching sides
to the Queen side this is not how I
envisioned this game going I just shook
his head yeah he's gonna say he probably
should be at this point I mean I think
9h for earlier chopping the Queen was
probably the way to call call blacks
Bluff so he he actually wants to break
open the queenside for his rook on a1
but all the blacks pieces are
concentrated because f3 g for dynamic
here so you do it to be very careful if
you're LaVon but if there's no concrete
threat because how many so f3 is hit
four times by black but it's also
protected four times by white this is
ridiculous the concentration yeah and
okay white is gonna have a full board
control but the problem is given how
blacks pieces have coordinated so well
on the kingside this is just now from a
practical point of view what what LaVon
wanted to answer Quinn's question from
the twitch ad not only is just calm
covering the isle of man it is our event
I'm not sure that the memo has been
gotten that it is called the feed HS
calm grants whist chess calm has fully
partnered and sponsored the event with
feed a so anywhere you you see that
event it is officially the feed HS
dot-com grant Swiss so huge huge memo
that needs to be known there if that's a
question that indeed we will be the
official coverage of the event on site
and it is our event so there you go soon
in no more reasons to follow and you'll
be you'll be watching it right here at
twitch TV slash chess so alright night
comes to f3 well there's some sacrifices
for both sides here and here in Bishop
f4 because it's a night f3 is hanging I
thought he's gonna try Bishop takes f6
now there's Knight takes h4 even yeah
helps take back and drop does it oh wow
but the thing is white is up a piece
right for how many pawns gonna be three
pawns which in this particular position
gives black good compensation because
yeah weak white king Wow goes all
anything that I can laugh in the face of
danger of the discovered check here and
this might have been the way to do it
yeah that looks good so originally I I
said admit that I suggested not h4 with
the thought that Knight f3 and Queen h2
would be an attack but you look at it
and actually no b55 comes with chap no
way he wanted he's now two pieces a just
resigns that was a complete turnaround
yeah at that fell apart quickly let's uh
let's bring up the analysis board and
see how that one ended because that was
not the storyline we expected what
happened in this position right here it
feels like the sacrifice was unnecessary
well I think he's just all this peace
are tied up with each other right so
when he put in that enough three times
before there are a lot of white pieces
attacking that square so you removed one
of the guards right and if you take on
FX here on g5 back with the pawns have
taken on e4 that move probably lost the
game on the spot yeah turns out but if
you took on g5 stay with the pawn what
was you gonna do something like this
you're still in the game yeah very much
I mean black would have been okay and
maybe still with some pressure I don't
think it's clear who wins this game at
this point remember all the resident was
down on the clock as well yeah um so I I
don't think it's fair to say that LaVon
doesn't go on to win that game but okay
I mean that was not how we thought it
would finish Levon Aronian doing what he
has been predicted to do by our smarter
chess predictions let's um let's remind
everybody who made us be tuned in and
who these players are while we have have
a second Levon Aronian and Olly Reza
firoozeh our two competitors there you
go the young man from Iran rising
superstar 16 years old 16 years of age
as he would like to say to sound more
mature he is I am sixteen years of age
he doesn't just sound more mature he's
like in the future right now ya know
he's uh he's playing chess like a beast
doesn't doesn't uh uh he does have a lot
of room to grow I guess on the chess
board because he wants to get in that
twenty eight hundred room but you know
definitely definitely much wiser chess
player than I all say that so talk about
who Levon Aronian is number one in
Armenian number one in your hearts pawn
check the dog is actually number one in
my heart his dog who made an appearance
earlier before we were live maybe pawn
check he'll come back I hope so the fans
will get to see that's a cutie cutie dog
anyway these are the two guys you're
watching thanks for being with us this
is the 2019 a speech has championship
we've got about 4,000 of you and let's
remind you of the next matchup because
right after this this is a doubleheader
if you happen to be randomly tuning in
you are in for a treat we have a long
long Childre day right after this Robert
Robert can't stop talking about this
matchup I was almost gonna question like
white you know what is going on with you
but it's an amazing matchup because I
think you know everyone loves Sasha Gray
shook can't wait for the post match
interview right nobody Kuwait you but
Artemia I think he's a little under the
radar despite just skyrocketing into the
terrain he just isn't very well known to
many people but as grow shook himself
said this might be he's the Chuck Norris
of Russia and probably one of the
superstars for years to come well while
we're talking about events coming up
let's remind you that right after that
we have the fish of random World Chess
Championship quarterfinals opening
ceremony today we will decide who plays
who you could have guys like a car
Nakamura facing off against yonder pom
Yoshi in the first round who knows right
two of the favorites maybe to win the
whole thing
it's gonna be a random draw we are
excited about it we'll find out who
plays who what their colors are to start
and really set the tone for the weekend
here so all right back to the game here
Aronian with a 2-1 lead in the
five-minute portion this game currently
looking also decent for for black I
guess not necessarily special for either
side but well LaVon just went to roll up
his sleeves he's getting ready for this
end getting ready for the end game yeah
because if you look at this deponent a5
is a true weakness so if we do take on
c4 here the knight takes and c4 the rook
is tied down to the a file which is very
frustrating because if you look at
White's rooks on D 1 and E 1 at some
point white will try to push a 5 or put
a rook on d5 to attack the a5 pawn you
have many options there for white where
black doesn't have the kind of active
play that you need so that actually is
looking a bit problematic so but if you
don't try the Queen's it's wife's plan
still seems easy put a knight on d5 and
you just push forward here and not only
is the a 5-point weak but if the Queen's
on the board the black King side would
be weak so that's why I LaVon goes for
this
he puts the knight on c5 which is one
way to defend a5 in a weird way right
bringing the knight all the way to a
passive square but ali reza taking
advantage of the time lost by black to
over defend this weak pawn to just open
the center and look for some counter
play well he's sacrificing a pawn here
right so e takes d6 will win a pawn but
the thing is after Knight takes D 6 I
think I didn't want to trade the Knights
off and then rook takes T 6 then rook F
to c8 and you have this backward palm
which is not good news if you're trying
to win endgame however you are up a pawn
yep and you can play this you can go
rookie to after that end of that line
the bring your king run that King to d1
get that pawn some defense and then
start trying to trade a pair of rooks
and you
should be able to press in the end game
and probably win it yeah it would be a
little tricky I mean black has rook c5
and maybe double rooks try to get some
pieces off but okay no it would
definitely be one a2 result position for
white and I guess we're gonna find out
how many how many winning chances there
really are cuz we're getting that exact
line you predicted look at you went full
full Bobby has prediction shoes there I
didn't eat my Wheaties but yeah baby
yogurt part of the bananas myself it was
great they're actually they're very the
texture was great you need to be nice
balance yeah raspberries you have the
tart bananas potassium here comes that
King though you called it okay well and
then the next couple moves you know once
he you just make sure that he doesn't
hang any pawns but you want to double
your rooks on the file and then put one
on the fifth rank and then try to trade
off a rook up there so don't be
surprised if lon puts that work on see
it on c5 which prevents a trade and over
protects the a 5.30 or it is because
that meat that's the one target that
white is trying to take advantage of but
with both rooks on the fifth rank it's
very hard time getting there so don't be
surprised now if version goes rook d3 oh
well now it's okay Brooke have three
tries to stop it but you might still see
t3 I don't know I think your prediction
may still be accurate because just
getting to pass pawn yeah breaking the
structure could be good for a white
right because right now everything is
held by this backward C to pawn being
held back by the b4 pawn so the passed
pawn is going to be key as you can see
in any endgame the opportunity to get a
new queen is honestly the usually the
most deciding factor in in close to
equal end games okay so here comes black
is gonna try to trade f2 for a5 both
sides might get past pawns here oh but
there's a big tactical problem for white
here is if you'll rip d8 to d5 we wait
giving up the f2 pawn immediately so I
can get to d5 exactly there's there some
calculation to be had here to the
Batcave here we go because got a trade
right yeah sorry I meant that move order
and one of the things to calculate is
he's a little rook air-five seized upon
a game
yeah but then see c3 or c4 right those
double pawns won't do you any favors
okay yeah yeah so too slow too slow
there boy your nickname in high school
too she's lived in - slowed and that was
that
that was that you called it but even
this is interesting right because now
black has two basketballs but White's
pawn is more advanced over it'd be five
there and try to push the a pawn feels
like white should be better but I agree
with you this is gonna be much more of a
full race okay Livan trying to prepare
for that doesn't even take the bait yet
but if he gets the king in a more active
spot ideas of ideas of going for that
kind of line are gonna be more relevant
yep tacking the pawn makes sense if you
go f4 here then the rook just goes back
to f5 then King h5 King g4 and in comes
the King and you the rook is tied down
to the fence this g3 pawn which is not a
not something you really want of course
is why you want to be more active yeah I
like it put the rook out of five you're
threatening both rook h5 why why yeah
why that why why why I have no idea I
wish I could answer he wants to meet
because I'm kind of like c3 with a
breakage to check perhaps or c4 yeah so
is he just trying to get just it so
clearly took away two kings path right
right it's really hard to to get excited
about that move yeah I'm still a little
befuddled here I mean just felt like the
King needed to go to g4 for active play
and now for c4 that's a passed pawn he's
Prince came back
Wow here comes no rook d5 wouldn't work
I assume the trade and the black king
can Corral the pawn in time but then
white rice King it's pretty close there
yeah rook d5 chop job king c2 kaindi
three and that's a unless there's some
sort of Kingston no there no there's
easily winning out that came we'll have
to back up and the white king gets in so
he wouldn't have trade I guess his point
was yeah he's an over cage to check and
try to go over up g2a now over cage
three okay I'll play a little tickle
here but it's gonna be a race c5 takes
rook d3 to stop rook c3 mm-hmm the rook
will give check the king will move okay
all the arrests it doesn't want the race
yeah he said look at me I'll go past it
for now yeah
passive because even if this King gets
all the way in front the white king will
dominate that battle
yeah and despite the time advantage on
the clock I don't think that's gonna
save lavon's endgame here he's up 15
seconds for the time being but this
looks like a pretty good endgame
technique so far by the youngster yeah
the only good news that LaVon has here
is that the pawn b3 is a backward pawn
so that the King starts running for them
king d3 in this position I Emilio rook
b1 it forced your king right back to c2
to protect that pond oh and we're gonna
find out all the resident might be
prepared to sacrifice the d5 the meep on
c5 rook takes and run the King oh yeah I
like it I love it there it is wait oh
yeah hey could try to change the move
order he couldn't yep
and some rooks III check feels rooks III
king b v b3 there is threats of rooks e2
there if you have to play rook beat you
and the King comes to have six nice it's
not gonna be so clear at all I mean I I
think from a practical perspective
pushing pushing the envelope there with
the King makes sense you often want
activity and rook in games versus
passive defense but the concrete
calculation of that may may mean that it
wasn't as good as we thought yeah this
rook c2 idea is brilliant because c6
would be the movie you want to play here
that might be what he missed right and
that's a key thing that rook c2 was a
threat says now that King gets it in
time so he'll take on a five I think but
never book takes e5 before Soho okay
here comes King e6 yeah I really would
have taken that pawn 85 so I would have
had an outside passed pawn in the rook
endgame I wondered if King e7 was
slightly more accurate actually to
actually avoid what's gonna happen here
cuz then King d8 check you could have
gone here but then rook h2 probably rook
h2 and I'm still too slow okay so it
didn't matter I was worried about this
scenario where the King goes here and
the White King everyone is sort of
shouldering the black King with
opposition which allows a chat and the
King just has to go away so that it may
still be a winning in him for white I
wanted to bring the king of front but as
Robert pointed out getting yourself
animating net is less than ideal huh
don't get yourself innovating that Dan
also Nick also a nickname in high school
why snags the a pawn it says I'll be
back to b6 king DX that King right back
to b6 now I'll push de pawn
too many passed pawns for white here
yeah g5 is
just what the doctor ordered doctor
order but I don't think it's gonna save
the game he'll get here with cheque but
the king will come to b6 yeah and it's
not gonna matter white white spawns are
just way too fast
yeah here I think you could probably go
rookie to check and that's a 5 yeah if
I'm a 5 I think I'll move the King and
there's just too much you broke a 4 can
we fight with tempo ouch right is it out
shout out down population you I wasn't
gonna go there but clearly I've made
influence on your place on you made some
very negative influence on me just like
my real kids ok - ok - OH
c7 said let me get a new queen yeah this
is over it was pretty funny last night
when you were leaving and you were like
goodnight and like got the whole house
yeah good night Robert good night Robert
good night Robert it was like an echo a
chorus it was lovely
all right game over time match two - we
have a match today although reza takes a
sip is that a chest comm mug or is he
just happy to see me look at that yes
branding right there look at that up to
Nick for sending that across across the
seas they also send him the what if it
is someone's like one of those old
switchboards like behind him yeah though
I expect him to turn around and start
Minority Report
he's like Tony Stark can get time travel
is possible like I've been trying to
figure that out honestly I have no idea
we have to ask it also could be like a
tool I have one of those in my
garage you hate it looks like pin boards
we got like hammers and things hung and
hang your rake on it very useful
he's fly board anyway shout-out to the
emotes they're useful right now set for
nine one flash in the flash in the
subscription there we appreciate your
support
all the premium members hanging out and
chest TV chat bone broth is here HT 9090
says just a window shade what I don't
think that's a window shade I said that
that used Levon Aronian goes right from
playing chess with us to being
interrogated in a room the light blinds
them and we're
were you nine a four okay so we're back
to the English this is this is Levon
Aronian is kind of go-to weapon here in
English I'm expecting him to continue to
try move orders that maybe throw out the
youngster because even despite how
strong all the res is you and I both
know like experience and move orders is
something that can take a really long
time
right it's how it's how sometimes
players have weaknesses expose where
they don't relieve lack knowledge but
they can get put in a position that
where they're just not comfortable right
and so I like the English from a
practical perspective for Levon to
continue to try to poke at all the
Reza's repertoire and see where you can
get an advantage and it also cribs weak
squares in this one you see the bishop
on c5 but the bishops on c5 so then I
can go there later yes the real purpose
get rid of this guy is your main goal
yeah you might say well the Bishop on e7
is not doing anything but it does defend
that square in its if the knight one
that you can capture at any moment so
look at Levon build up the tension here
wait to tension no pieces are really
attacking each other beside the bishop
yep but look for a rook F to d1 maybe
pawn to d4 perhaps you know pawn to e4
for white as well and then pawn to d4 so
what has various options here and black
is quite limited because there's not
much space for a Larissa to use for his
pieces well you talk about tension the
fact that this B pawn can't really move
safely cuz the c6 square becomes
vulnerable so again this is a position
where like you okay you called the move
there's a lot of tension because despite
the piece is optically looking well
placed it there it's very difficult for
black here to deal with the comingcoming
ways that white can push the Knights
around okay this is this is a nice move
in a lot of positions you might even
just be willing to part with the bishop
here if it means your might gets access
to this square very common in this
structure just to highlight that's some
random thing just to show that okay if
this happens without other tactical
consequences in some cases this
transition can favor black here I don't
think that would work because white has
perfectly prepared himself to do things
like win a pawn on c7 yep but Bishop h5
has purpose it also spies both the rook
on d1 a the pawn on e - and that goes to
show that you know maybe black also
wants to get rid of this Bishop on c5
because then d4 square and lavona is no
fear he says alright I'm gonna break
open the center cuz Robert mentioned it
earlier and you know how LaVon loves me
you have never admitted
but yeah he loves it but it makes a lot
of senses of rock on d1 the Queen on d8
and whenever that's the case rook
staring down at a queen you really want
to open the file
yep so what can black do here you don't
want to take on d4 that's for sure that
is if you take on d4 we take with the
night and you would assume if the
position becomes open that white is
gonna win material here and I know what
they say when you assume but this time
I'll go for it
not no no good for black to open things
up okay he takes that there has to be
some concrete follow up here because
that's not a move you want to play
there's no immediate threat now for
winning the night with a pin yep
and if before you know what didn't
suffice you can move your night away so
you impose 94 but Queen c4 here and this
is a big problem because if you take on
f3 yeah I just take back with my paw and
you're still pinned and if you go c6 to
protect I oh but then you can take on b6
with tempo so instead of Knight b6 go
Knights you go Knight c3 okay yeah nice
III would do the job of winning the pawn
right say went c6 first Bishop g2 though
you saved the bishop pear tree LaVon now
you can even play you for and okay III
kick one night Eve for kick another
night pop a knight in to b6 take on d5
golf upon yeah I like that I'm into
pawns
I'm glad you're into pawns anything else
you're into you a little weird I didn't
know how to answer that
good he's really the pawn stand high
school I went to a weird high school
Twickenham 2014 after I shouted out bone
broth platinum member tricking him it's
like I'm here too hey buddy
an extra pawn for LaVon here and he's
got the control file three-on-two that's
already advanced this isn't your normal
three on two or we're talking about the
long-term potential of the majority
yeah this is like Knight b6 and be far
away from a passed pawn here right I
mean this is not gonna be so much fun
yeah and blacks attempt at counter play
will have to be involved in the white
squares on the King side with Queen age
595 but it seems very very slow well we
know the chatters are here for an
opportunity to get a shout out but the
players are here for the prices let's
remind everybody what they're playing
for some
we didn't get into in the opening
ceremony this is our second to last
matchup in the first round of play after
as we said today is a doubleheader so
right after this we have our tinea
versus Gro shook but 16k on the line for
just 16 players in these first rounds
and then we got eight players competing
for 12k four players competing for 12k
that's a money round and then two
players for $10,000 pretty fun stuff and
that's what's at stake here for the
speeches championship so pretty nice
yeah with that kind of money I think
LaVon can get a new light in I mean I
he's blinding me that's why I'm looking
at him I don't look directly at him
right we've got the attack as you said
started with queen h5 which wanted
Knight g5 to follow
LaVon tried to proactively defend this
with a move like h4 I wonder if he we
got it it wasn't necessary right he's
gonna get the Queens off the board or he
wants to get the Queen's off the board
cuz then he gets to focus again on his
extra pawn on the Queen side but what if
all he reza plays a move like Queen f3
right just keep the tension I'm
wondering if maybe LaVon made his life a
little harder by opening the Kings side
as I say it though the Queen here the
seventh ranked that belongs to white I'm
sorry to interrupt you but firoozeh
would buy some new sunglasses with the
prize money is it because of just said
before the match oh I missed the stat
okay amazing yeah you would buy some new
sunglasses you know how the kids feel
about it there there are oakley ray-ban
these days you know those kids you turn
into a dog you know those kids get off
my lawn those kids looking for some dad
dance a grandpa you know all right
the Queen comes to f5 the reason it
didn't go to f3 everyone is because it
wants the g5 square for the night to go
here so a little bit more accurate but
if you're just getting here almost 4500
of you clearly we have a very good match
it is a 2-2 scores you can see and I
think we're in for a thriller today yeah
it's interesting in this moment how
white
make progress I'm thinking at some
moment to play c6 to get my second rook
on c6 and attack the f6 pawn but I think
Kim G 2 was a very smart move Knight f4
check would scare me because the G pawn
is pinned but then I go King f3 is he
gonna do it do it
bring the King out do it do it do it it
might actually welcome okay but even
this is fine because you you kind of
gain a tempo by getting to h2 because we
back a couple moves everyone you're not
thrilled about the King being on the G
file at the Queen but by inducing the
knight to come in and then going to h2
look what happened black just had to
bring the knight right back to e6 right
so you kind of gained a tempo now maybe
Roberts idea of c6 as possible I guess
the main worry is okay he plays rook c3
because of it the main worry is this
idea we continue to highlight that the
night will come to g5 yeah I see
actually a very good common the chat
don't cry wolf said not 9 f4 right away
save it as a threat I agree with that
and then ofor would might have been a
bit rushed
yeah because it allowed LaVon to regroup
but his work on c3 and yeah become very
difficult for black to get an attack
here because if I go g4 at some point
for white I stuck because you want Queen
Jade so he can go Charlie go f5 it's a
moment but g4 here says nope you're not
getting to be 5 I like it in here comes
f6 is a target which undermines
protection of the night so yeah Knight
f4 was definitely a little rushed I just
love how dominate the night is on d5
right that move feels like if we're
talking the emotional miss of the move
right if you'll think it just took the
wind out of black sails they're
emotional this isn't work ok I wasn't
questioning you okay I trust your vocab
rook to d8 now there's rook takes f6 but
it allows 52 so may be unnecessary the
real problem with rook d8 if you're Olly
Reza is what are you what are you gonna
do big guy sit on me
you're gonna take d6 and give me a pass
pawn yeah so there's no real threat here
right what what should Y do before baby
I don't know
well I don't I want don't play b4 or
else I'm not sure about is this if that
Knight moves away from d5 that gives me
the a2 square for my queen what about
this yeah I'm probably still go Queen a2
I was like let me go attack you
B to pawn you've gotta let me good night
you six check though okay okay okay cuz
I'm okay I'm a good friend there you go
yeah good a don't know if that worked
but okay you got away with it here comes
f6 though
LaVon gonna do this thing the clean way
with limited counter play for black
maybe even King g2 if he wants to just
really yeah
G for King g3 mmm-hmm push forward Queen
takes f6 now oh you shouldn't go rook FA
and then win the f3 pawn but that still
is winning for white the second time
around brings the King to g2 maybe you
should have played that move first I was
one of the reasons I wanted the king on
g2 was just to overprotect f3 but no
he's now he's lost his chance White's
still in great shape but c66 only 5
seconds for Purusha I've been waiting
for c64 so long no how long too long
create to counter play actually I I
don't know that it's really counter play
look at what you did to yourself don't
judge alright so things might now go to
f4 and I agree with you that does look
very very promising here for white but
at least I have something to see what Oh
Queen 3 double blunder Dan that wasn't a
nickname it's just a common description
Oh actually he could have taken on c6
there instead of Wow
roni and give unnecessary counter play
only once point 3.8 about to lose on
time you have Knight cheat - just a
mocking we can't take this 99 h3 you
made it so his Queen G - wait - what
five guards h6 just in time he's
sacrificing the queen with rook c7 and
rookie suppose me we missed it that's a
check Oh Queen g8 I think he missed rook
c7 in her MS oh he did Queen takes h7
should still be good for white look at
you enough but duty miss that was sick
hey rook okay he still gets the win but
we'll back this thing up like juvenile
and shake what our mama gave us in this
case wasn't analysis board look at this
check here he missed rook
I think in this position here rook c7
first is killer the King either has to
go to the eighth rank or East six and
rookie 7 was made up
he missed it okay he still got the win
but that would have been that would have
been the fancy schmancy way to finish
things off right it socio it's funny
because I wonder if LaVon realizes he
missed that cuz even though he won the
game yeah something that these top
players get really upset about yeah
they're like yeah they put on that face
yeah so does they make the Nakamura a
fun place like right did I miss that
yeah I don't even know if many people
lunch which know that that's where the
the email comes from right I have no
idea about the emo but I do know that
firoozeh right now just trying to break
open the queenside
yeah this one here naka h3o wait no
anyway nock age three what a moment and
well screen age three yeah we just
played trying to say if you take me on
f3 we have opposite color bishops but my
bishop on the white squares will be
better than yours in the dark squares
because in particular there's the it's
hard on the f7 square that if you don't
have a light square bishop I can just
keep mine on that diagonal and amp up
the pressure there
so okay Brooke a7 comes to mind here for
a Larissa just stopping any Bishop e7
nonsense rook b6 here for but the bishop
stays on that diagonal as you said I'm
happy for it to be there is a Bishop e6
at the right moment is make the trade
work a six I like that move even better
get that rook off the seventh ring one
of the issues with Bishop e6 was maybe a
trade in the sack of the pawn a little
positional yeah you go right just go
that how the knight can dominate a
bishop yeah well back up real quick
gonna show that'll knee nails this board
but I think one of the issues was that
if this trade happens this is a good
tactic to keep in mind you sack and then
you fill a light square and this Bishop
is no good combined with the rook on the
seventh ring so I think that's what
LaVon was worried about but this is a
better approach anyway especially if the
position starts to become open
is he gonna is he gonna be take with c5
yeah well look at you you're all about
this pawn sex usually I'm the one second
you're sure
you're in the wrong show I think you
didn't get the memo Joe zero to three
says my wife's been wondering why I've
been watching more chefs is there
follow-up I think it was it just like
there you go Pepa moso Platinum Member
the chess TV Chad throwing out gifted
premium memberships like their candy
we love that guy oh that's the end of
the month
what sorry dad fail dad fail it's okay
forgive you you'll go trick-or-treating
great time he you won't I'm gonna
be in Oslo Norway the kids are already
mad we were gonna do a family I think
I'm gonna dress up in costume on the
show on October 31st whatever in in Oslo
what wait everyone the surprise you
don't know what I'm gonna wear you're
using a dress of as Magnus okay then why
is just dominating my yeah this is this
is a c6 square that's happy to see me
what happened here let's back this thing
up my idea of taking and c5 was played
because the whole point is c4 shuts off
the bishops protection and maybe opens
up for the bishop here but white gets in
with tempo another tempo because of c6
the night lands on c6 okay it's it's a
really domination yet I mean this was a
sacrifice he played on purpose and at
some point C 4 is coming this is the
idea yeah it just feels like you know
shouldn't be good enough they were
Snooki one even you get c4 and I'm not
sure how powerful will be 25 makes a lot
of sense to - okay one Queen to b6 or
slithering into with a red nope okay you
want full drinking on me oh you're more
of Crabbe and Goyle definitely more of a
crab all right Queen 85 there's a
problem for black I like that move
though get out of my house yep Queen a
three point eight three just keep poking
maybe see for them you have two Queen a3
yeah no but you're right the more I look
at it feels like the idea LaVon was
going
or while nice in theory just the
accuracy really the key thing was that
Knight g4 came with tempo here the tempo
here to e5 with tempo because without
that move you were looking at a position
where the knight is how to play and c4
was happening right but changed
everything it looks like all the rest is
in pretty good shape once again by the
way to level the score of the match I
mean this is gonna be a great one yeah
this is gonna be good
exciting stuff here we're already off to
a great start and you know LaVon lost
the first game you totally had an
oversight and since then they've been
very back and forth a week we've had no
draws right no draws did they get the
man with a there was around that's
awesome you know draws today you're
right I haven't even realized that so
Queen a5 back you couldn't take on a6
because there's back rank checkmates the
bishop on d6 covers the escape score on
h2 so that's why taking this bishop on
e6 was not possible
last move sorry Batcave messed up Queen
a5 Queen takes a6 with rook e1 Oh
actually just take first right yeah if
you want checkmate I don't know what's
better check later a queen these days
checkmate
okay some things haven't changed so h4
plate and LaVon is setting up kind of a
long-term net over here right it might
be pretty short term feel like Queen if
I'd that four oh wow
I might just sacrifice my bishop and say
who cares about the bishop suddenly the
attack being created so much so that all
the residents be four by the way cutting
off the Queen and if you trade take a6
I'm a tree oh no there's queen of one no
but then there's Bishop H to show the
whole thing before takes takes takes
check there's no Queen of one I forgot
there was a d3 pawn it's just me I was
like wait Queen of one oh wow c4 well
the point is to sell you your queen
can't take on any of these variations
yeah so he'll just take on c4 oh but
take on c4 pawn takes c4 and then blacks
ago c3 to cut off the circulation of the
Queen in the e1 Square that's not gonna
be fun
for does the same thing look at it yet
this is one of those positions that
Levon Aronian kind of developed a name
for himself as a swindler right kind of
at some point even joked himself being a
coffeehouse trickster right nobody's
ability to just sense right where there
was an opportunity from a practical
perspective white was dominating this
game control over the Queen side a
knight on c6 the Queen on a5 look at him
takes off the red jacket just kind of
just kind of settling in right those
enemy Bob he's it made him he's gonna
made him LaVon has just completely
turned this game around is the only
survivor up takes the a like Queen d8 to
trade off the Queen's but I was gonna
say you have to keep the rooks on the
board yeah but that's sad yeah cuz white
black would just start opening oh he
takes some questions takes D 3 and if
Queen takes a sick Queen to check and
Queen e1 is mate
yep he does it I think yeah yeah I think
he missed that exact idea he shakes his
head because he played this thinking
takes I get to take here and there's no
discovered check but the point obviously
is that takes Queen e2 is mate
real quick will showed on the analysis
or as they start the next one but it's
interesting because that wasn't even the
only way to win that in that position so
yeah there's no oversight
you know we went opponents pieces under
attack sometimes like they need to move
it or protect it right totally forget
that they don't have to write the rules
of check don't state right Pisan attack
you've got a move it's the human nature
right it's one of the emotional things
that affect our approach and the moves
we consider in calculations the
computers have completely
I think they've improved top level chess
where the best players mode are better
than ever at just remembering those sort
of you know little mini pro tips yeah
but in a practical situation not so much
time on the clock difficult and Levon
Aronian takes a two-game lead in blitz
let's remind everybody about our smarter
chess predictions where if we can what
what did we what did we think was gonna
happen here in the 5-1 portion we've
those are our power rankings for the 5-1
that's what they were coming in do we
have our smarter chess predictions there
we go five one score six and half three
naps oh oh no five and a half three and
a half so we're right on pace a two-game
lead for the Montreux nion right now in
the five plus one portion
yeah and I saw that in the chat Tisa
important win for the one I agree that
was a really essential win there yeah
and I see smarter chests saying it's
March si plus to referring yourself in
the third person
only the ROC can get away with it the
rock is everyone's favorite narcissist
everyone else you can't just refer to
yourself like that or unless you're
self-deprecating with made-up nicknames
in high school he's made up nicknames in
high school dan is amazing how quickly
you know but we have this this structure
here that is Benoni like but noni ish
yeah and the bishops are being traded on
the dark squares which typically should
be pretty good for white mhm
that relieves some the tension on the d6
square perhaps but at the same time
usually the best pieces the dark square
bishop so if I get that off the board my
just whole structure feels much safer
and the problem for black is you want to
play C for to put your net on c5 but
bring your pieces away from the King
side when you don't have bishop is
problematic that's what White's trying
to do here f4 I mean you highlighted a
good point that d6 is kind of the the
crux of black structure right and often
with the dark square Bishop that's
something you poke out but getting rid
of the darks for Bishop as it opens the
King kind of gives you full
justification to just blow things open
he plays d6 the problem is he's not
actually trying to take oh he is gets a
new queen or how many times he's done
that's how many times they've done that
today it's crazy he just has no problem
giving me on material to get a new queen
yeah though it's actually been three
games crazy so that would be six then
rook b6 looks like a really good move in
the point everyone is that now on takes
you can trade because word my rook oh go
on can't take it okay so I begin where
things go where did the red jacket go he
took it off I told you last game I
missed it yeah he kind of threw it off
Michael Jackson style - he just like
threw it off so I guess rook b6 is meant
by Brooke a to d1 protecting both the d6
pawn and the Queen on D - yeah I like it
and renewing the threat on the 97 I
don't know he goes it's a miracle b4
after rook to d1 I like it though he
found rook to b6
so you one of these positions where
because why to sacrifice a pawn if you
can get an attack going very quickly or
gain a very important space you're doing
well but there are some issues here yeah
I think you want to take you five first
because opening up DF file is likely
better tactical possibilities regardless
of whether you have something immediate
yep
right um I agree so I'm anticipating
LaVon will take you five using the time
advantage he's earned on the clock which
again hasn't been a storm and we've
talked a lot of us since the beginning
given all the residence reputation as
the the much faster player but if we're
talking about what the tempo has been in
the five-minute portion over all the von
Aronian has definitely been been up on
the clock more often than not it's true
and can you take on f4 here perhaps
takes on a four I just want to gain a
tempo so if you take back on that for I
get 96 with you know the game of a move
okay he doesn't go for it though
instead he plays before it feels like he
has a decent feel for the position
anyway yeah because he's he's gaining
til I'm trying to kick the pieces around
before he Corral's the pawn because he's
also giving himself the d5 square well
just move your night somewhere silly
then open 95 and he take so now live on
tape wait is there B takes c3 here by
any chance
wow that would be crazy I don't think
that six with the Queen takes takes
shake and bake because the Queen d2 is
also hanging yeah this this would be way
too much yeah it almost works he just
takes back on e5 and all the reza is
trying to just defend things in a simple
way maybe rookie so no but now that now
the pawns on pinned oh where do you just
miss that so another nice hanging yeah
the other night in the Rookery that is a
problem it's a huge problem so how can
he sacrifice the Brooks I'm not taking
you to that doesn't look Pleasant whoa
cakes on c3 Queen e5 the exchange
sacrifice is on but all of a sudden
there's like
weirdness with d6 coming I mean sorry d7
yeah
but the Queen Queen sevens almost a move
too but you don't take and take on beats
yeah so maybe why do ya white just takes
back here time to corral that pawn
before it's too late
and it's ER no actually rook takes f6
right now what a crazy move if you go
rook takes f6 Knight e4 though maybe
even better can you go back to the
second Seaver takes f6 because like kind
of everything was hanging rook takes f6
by the way if you take here I move back
with check oh yeah six oh my god man
that was the idea well when LaVon
finishes the job super quickly and he's
up three games in the match they're
gonna start the next one I'm uh I was
I'm gonna try to figure out what just
happened here so he doesn't take up six
which seems accurate
yeah his move is probably better let's
go now not sure what's going on here
rook takes f6 what are the key points in
that line if we bring up the analysis
board just to show how the last game
finished is that again if rook takes d1
rook f1 wala discovered check f6 might
have held everything so instead LaVon
just played the patient move Knight e4
bringing in more attackers and as the
game finished 94 rook d1 + f6 falls and
the main thing I guess is that if Knight
takes you have rook d6 yep right and if
Queen takes the night falls yep looks
good enough okay that's my translation
of why why they've resigned and Levon
Aronian has a three game lead if we're
keeping track at home this is where it
gets a little dicey right I mean this is
but if you were talking about the
storyline sort of expected Levon Aronian
is a stronger player right now there's
no debate on that from chess objective
perspective anybody in chat wants to
throw an opinion out there that says
otherwise it's just it's just talking
smack right because Levon Aronian has
been 2800 Ali Reza is not in his league
yet over the board but blitz bullet-time
scrambles that's what makes the speech
as championship what it is the 5-minute
portions
to be the best chance for the stronger
player to sort of flex right right and
build their lead and he might need it
headed into bullet so kind of heading
along what you thought would happen here
yeah absolutely I mean as you said
there's no debate LaVon is the higher
rated player that is just fact he's the
stronger player and he just is very well
versed and something you said earlier is
ringing sure things the experience right
because LaVon has experience in many
different positions it's not just about
the opening right and even that position
earlier when he went d5 sacrifice one
went c5 yeah which you had actually you
foresaw that so I was a great fine by
you but he realized that okay I may go
down a pawn but I will have very good
compensation for a pawn and LaVon
doesn't make the most of his chances
well you know what else is interesting
is even though we highlighted LaVon
doesn't play as much online blitz and
bullet as Holly Reza in terms of the SCC
LaVon is also the more experienced
player yeah right and and one thing I
think people forget is just how much the
increment makes the speech s
championship what we consider to be an
elite chess event I mean the high
quality chess that's played here you and
I talked in with Peter Lake Oh last year
at the isle of man who said he Tunes
into the SCC to see what kind of opening
secrets they reveal knowing that these
guys are often showing some prep and
really want to win this thing so the
point is it's it's not the same as just
the online time scrambles you see
narrative scheme for route of play where
they're flagging each other ruthlessly
the increment really brings out the high
quality chess and and that's something
that it will be will be good for all the
reservoirs or loses this match right to
get that experience Oh a hundred percent
I mean if you ask other is a you know if
you're gonna lose this match would you
be ok yeah I'm getting to play Levon
Aronian right hours on end right and
there is a lot to be learned from that
experience and right now here's a good
example of that Levon has spent 15
seconds although at a mid and a half yep
and we're in a position that it were
wise up upon but LaVon said I probably
studied this before I feel okay that I'm
gonna hold this position even if I may
be slightly worse I find just making a
drop but what I will say is this kind of
situation is very nice for ali reza he's
up upon a clean pond there's no real
risk in his position he can just try to
nurse this advantage and just create
difficulties for LaVon that said well
LaVon is LaVon and you know it's gonna
be hard to beat him yeah in
he again the fact that he's playing so
quickly just suggests that he kind of
feels confident black is gonna have
enough compensation to hold here a
three-game lead not gonna be the worst
was all in the world if he does get a
draw only 15 minutes left though in the
five-minute portion and I think as the
time patrols get faster all the resume B
feels a little more confident so uh
we'll see I think we're probably gonna
get about two more games in the five
minute had to guess right I think we'll
get at least one more after this B for
now taking advantage of the pinned split
rook b3 can I have two right rook b3
we're gonna get a trade and you know
White's up a clean pawn as you said to
one one actually maybe you won't trade
if I see five just to keep that pin
alive it's been annoying and I wouldn't
have taken on 85 like a Larissa did but
perhaps he felt like yeah - but yeah if
you were p3 c5 coming it just feels like
you're little stuck yeah let's look at
that actually that's probably why he
played rook c4 but if the Brooke to b3
had been played c5 and everything was
pinned yeah yeah
Queen e8 comes next but but that means
what the movie plays he's giving back
his paulette yeah this doesn't look
particularly good for firoozeh for sure
and again
LaVon knows this line very well I think
Queen d6 will be the move keeps an eye
on c7 I'm having a hard time
understanding this like if you're on the
announce for just a couple moves Danny
yep like before B takes a five here
I mean White's up a pawn yeah and your
rooks are awkwardly placed I'll play
rugby - yeah that's what I thought was
gonna be played and maybe there's some
kind of queen d4 that doesn't do much
real Queen d2 so I'm not really sure
it's a little late to right it takes
before that's where it goes wrong
Oh ATX before then the back ring yeah
yeah so maybe his in fact let's show how
crazy this leg could be if takes the
Queen's extra point takes before yep so
this is one of those positions where
again we were talking about the
practical aspects of these two players
and giving LaVon credit because credit
was due
but this position again just showed how
tricky it was for white despite being up
upon this was never gonna be an easy
problem to solve now black has regained
that pawn
and probably the a pond is the most
powerful passer on the board yep
yeah no it's very yes super well played
right now by Aronian and he's up look
how much time he's up yep who would have
thought thing to be up two and a half
minutes against a larissa but I think it
also goes to show that a Larissa has
huge respect for LaVon yes of course
everyone should but maybe some nerves as
well yeah maybe maybe a little bit too
much maybe needs to trust himself pick
up the speed a little bit I think that's
one thing that the three minute kind of
brings out a little bit so we'll see if
he can find himself in the faster
portion here but right now yet way down
on the clock and also down three games
in the match yeah but now I guess he can
take it if he trades Queens off feels
like it's not not gonna be much of risk
because you can take on d6 put your rook
on c3 tie black down to the a pawn and
and just say okay you'll put your books
double Brooks in the a foul and then
what right we can just shuffle back and
forth you might need to do that because
if you give LaVon one more chance to get
tricky here and keep the Queens on the
board maybe he goes for some sort of
okay he does it right don't let the
Vaughan create some sort of mating net
out of nothing like we've already seen
him do in this match a couple times so
exactly I'm saying has happened and well
where's that king nf1 going where's this
end destination you can bring it to a-1
but okay you lose pretty awkward g5 g4 I
like it as just kind of a long-term way
to make sure everything on the Kings
side is gonna sit tight probably bring
the king up first if chief or you might
allow Rugby five yeah so bring the king
up to defend now maybe g4 yeah and the
good thing for black is at any moment
when this rook on b3 attack something
you can just bring your rook on the same
rank as a rookie fiving over K five
everybody 16 over K six like right you
defend everything by bringing the rook
up so he goes for g4 now as predicted
and I think again the result probably
isn't gonna be a peaceful one here but
the longer you get longer this game goes
on you look at now almost a three look
at the time edge for Aronian right
really bringing the focus today putting
pressure on the youngster so I think
this game continues to go time scrambles
change everything right whether it
objectively should be a draw or not
d five okay I thought he's gonna try
some kind of rookie eight check and then
put the rook on you want you to go after
the h2 pawn that's a really good thing
about putting your pawn in G for ya as
you submit the pawn h2 in its tracks so
if you look down to h1 you have what I
ended up giving away giving up the a
pawn to do it yeah it actually still
looks pretty reasonable you look over
key a check no I'm gonna keep the rooks
on the board that was the key things
missing okay Wow
never q1 rookie one this is how you
create winning chances even if the
position still should objectively be
okay for white with 30 seconds I do not
want to be playing this but not at all
we could see a four game lead here that
would be this would be a much much more
than smarter chess predicted take that
yeah take that take that martyr
that's so smarter chess you think that
was his nickname in high school
smarter yes okay I'll put a pawn f6 you
know keep everything defended and white
doesn't really have many moves so rook
you young here comes the rook to e1 both
threatening backdoor checks along with
the H pawn falling this is just so tough
this is look at him he's flexing those
uh you know the Armenian school of chess
knowing knowing there are chances there
how many times does he sacrificed a pawn
and had long-term compensation that
drove all he was a crazy today at least
three yeah so h4 discouraged force
coming get the rook back he's kind of
debating he doesn't know if he wants to
it's not for F any targets okay f4 is a
little better everyone because then
Harry is a real wizard on the h-file
instead of trading it off now Harry's a
passed pawn but the problem is you've
left this white pawn also start pushing
oh I like that
yeah what's gonna happen it's gonna be a
race gonna be a race do you want g3 and
settle for the draw cuz you're that
worried about the race I'm pretty
worried actually this has gotten it's
gotten real dicey because suddenly white
is in the ideal spot if you study your
divorce key rook end games getting your
Brooks behind the pawn is it always the
ideal spot sacrifices on there too with
two passers way but g3 I've rook f3 and
then I go G to no you got this
although the deep pond is really fast
yeah I don't every check King f6 or f5
you go to have six so you can run to e7
I think so no I don't think so
you bring up the analysis board and you
do it if you go King f6 when I go d6
okay you go h2o you won't check yeah
that's so important so lady because I
figures with Tempe I was a d7 but the
problem is what we analyzed is happening
okay ali reza settles on not allowing
the check because of those lines but
he's still in big trouble queen takes up
four completely playable here unless he
finds a way to maybe make it a little
harder but he goes for it i don't you
think it's whose chance they're better
here didn't live on is gonna win this or
do you think IRS is gonna hold
I think gold one's gonna win look at the
clock he's got five seconds to a minute
and thirty this is and and look at look
at the experience they're keeping the
Queen centralized rather than playing
forcing Tempe moves this is this is
really gonna be instructive for those
looking to wonder how you convert on
these the Queen wants to be in a spot
like this where you create problems
right now d7 is not possible but I've
been giving the forcing tempo the Queen
wants to continue to take squares and
make life difficult for the king and
rook now Queen b5 check forces it and
the king can enter because of rookie
seven King f8 d7 Queen B eights made yep
and if king of seven and and the rook
moves anywhere else the king will come
to e6 hey just for signs yeah and
actually I know the ending here on time
oh we won on time yeah because if D
seven years ago Queen b7 yep d7 Queen b7
he's frozen
wow that was great technique yeah
fantastic technique Levon Aronian takes
a four-game leading again just if we
back up okay the next game is underway
and I'll continue on this analysis board
to just show you if you just want to
take a note about how to convert on
these the big mistake that a lot of
people make in these physicians is they
just panic and start giving checks write
checks and you force the king and rook
together you want to create problems by
putting your queen on awkward diagonals
that make entry impossible make
coordination impossible d7 not possible
right and in these positions that you
give you give necessary checks but just
to improve the Queen's position
and continue to restrict one of the key
things about this move Robert is it
guarded this yes no rookie six and
something that's essential to point out
is that the rook wants it closed the
pawn the king because you've never very
far away one those checks may pick up
your room yeah you start to get checks
and and ways to pick up the rook so
because of that all the resident was
forced to stay as close as possible but
ultimately look at that technique forces
d7 and Queen b7 there would have been no
way to deal with this something like
check allows King e6 and it's just a
matter of time that was a brilliant game
yeah no I mean though that was a
fantastic piece of chess work that might
be the best game I've ever seen the
speed chess championship like that the
endgame technique maybe not the whole
game start to finish gonna say I think
you're suffering from a little but but
the endgame right just was a great end
game he will he sacrifice a pawn to a
down upon yo to keep the pressure he won
the H pawn decided to push the F pawn
during for the H pawn yeah sacrifice the
rook so that he can promote and they
don't mean you're right those really
start to finish especially we consider
the the line that he it was clearly
aligned prepared by the Vaughan
well-played right a sacrifice of a pawn
very early by black and and black just
but despite that black was in control
the whole game no you're right that's as
going down as one of the top games we
can remember maybe we're a little tired
this is our third speech as championship
show this week and we've got another one
right now but but for sure that was
about as good as it gets and as far as
instruction goes right that was just
that was exactly was textbook that's how
you want to learn to play with the Queen
versus the rook whether they have a pawn
or not creating those awkward positions
just brilliant stuff there from Livan a
four-game lead has only been overcome
one time by the favorite really in a
match which was Maxine Boucher the Grob
despite going down four games against
Wei Yi yep eventually came back all the
Reza has his work cut out for him I'm
gonna go ahead and call it that this is
very very likely the last five-minute
game which is probably good news for
Ferruccio
although considering how quick LaVon has
been the opening I'm not sure that's the
quicker time which those are gonna be
any better for him and I think that's
what I've been most impressed by is that
LaVon has just every single game
headed out of the gates and got a time
advantage well there is just took off
the headset well glad you liked that
Peppa moso in the chest TV chat said he
didn't really know how to play Queen
versus rook and hopefully that's some
instructor takeaways for you
alright Aronian takes - sorry Ferruccio
takes off the headset Aronian took a
rook on a7 and got out of Dodge
I don't really like this for white
though right like the thing is the pawn
a six we talked highlight the position
Cajon a6 is a potential target it's
cemented there by the pawn a five on the
flipside that pawn a5 might have
wandered too far in some end games at
the key Majan the Queen's off the board
it can quickly become a target but with
the Queens on the board look at that
King on f1 some of the light squares
around it you know I can at some point
like Queen c6 Queen b7 just trying to
get on the diagonal I don't really see
exactly what White's plan is but I know
that it involves developing the Queen
side with it cuz I'm kinda Knight c3
eventually Brooke c1 but you're not to
fully develop the Queen c2 is an option
for black at any moment I'm just and I
like that he continues to gain a tempo
right he played the move rook d8
everyone gaining a temp on the Queen for
discovery place the move Bishop e7 maybe
gaining a temple in the Queen here now
95 with the tempo hitting e3 it looks
pretty good hitting the Queen and the
big he doesn't go for it he just
develops says I don't need to rush
anything
oh the bishop wasn't brother would have
been particularly 9555 maybe it saves
the day okay but nicely 6 makes sense
anyway by putting a little bit of
pressure on the a5 pollen you make the
rook question its efforts to leave and
join the C file an e5 is a move that
you're trying to open with a diagonal
for the Queen so I can maybe sit on e6
but from what I met with Bishop c5
should I get that c5 score for my
Knights but the issue is if you start
you know getting your nice tick from d3
of them like Pawnee for you don't have
any pieces on your Kings side so I know
the White King is on too much trouble
just yet but you don't want to have all
your defenders removed in a potential
counter-attack will ensue
let's see Brooke same one Brooke c1
played for the first time in several
games Olly Reza firoozeh has a lead on
the clock and yeah that's worthy of
noting especially because
really has seemed like LaVon has
dictated the tempo is oh my gosh is that
66 he's got some what is he doing t3
what is that that's got to be the idea
what is that taking twice and winning b3
but oh wait there's a check on d1 I'm
gonna check on d5 and you pick up the
rook ah wait so right takes rook takes
okay let's look at the line if ruk takes
c6 rook takes d3 taken Ju oh can you
just I didn't look at this I'll be
honest but I was looking at this must
have been the idea yeah but you're right
I mean if we can get away with King e1
that because I'm a queen covers the B 4
squared yeah there's no mission before
check nothing like that
okay LaVon taking a second to think he's
got a question the kids tactics and say
are you really giving me that knight on
c6 he sits up all arrested maybe taking
a peek at the camera looking at his
opponent they can see each other via our
call and all the reza takes a quick jump
away from the camera what is this idea
there are some discoveries are with
Knight to d5 and that might be an option
as well right so after dice d5 hits the
Queen and then III is now hanging cuz
the pawn is pinned yeah but somehow
feels a little iffy so here's King g1 so
if you was isn't 95 still gonna be
pretty annoying
yeah 95 is still coming even though the
pawn is now not pinned it would be
doubled where's your queen going do I
have any I don't have any squares so 95
is evil gaeaf no that doesn't maybe g4
it's like the only move I mean quite
literally but that looks terrible it
does but at least I'm a losing material
yet I mean I can even that looks really
bad
yeah 95 looks good I'm not gonna lie
with 15 seconds left
this is officially our last game in the
five-minute segment remember after this
we move on to the faster portion three
minutes plus the 1 second increment
things only get more exciting from here
and much much more chess to come I'm
very confused right now not about what
you just said that all made sense okay
that's good
but ninety five just looks like it traps
that Queen knowledge for yeah what does
all the rest of thinking about it you
saying is time to double-check some
things but hmm did you just trying fair
maybe there's something even better
somewhere like but what would that be
what would that look like I would just
spend ninety five you're also up on the
clock yeah I'd say you just make the
move and should be advantageous for you
yeah he'll have to go G for off yeah I
don't know what he's doing here it it
honestly reeks a little bit of a lack of
experience from Mali resi maybe
overthinking the position I mean he we
should remind everybody that he
qualified let's run a better a daily
question to actually the daily question
asks you the community to help us figure
out what are maybe some more ways to get
qualifier spots available for the for
the main speeches championship we had
the women's speeches championship the
junior speeches chain became a couple of
other qualifiers one of which all the
rest of Purusha won and what are your
thoughts on that let's see what the
community has to say you can use the
hashtag speed chess interact with our
official Twitter account on chess calm
and let us know your thoughts well we'll
wait to get some tweets and we'll show
him when we have them so yeah again I
say that it was a natural thing for me
to think about cuz I'm wondering like it
just shows a little bit lack of
experience like what is he thinking
about here he just let his all of his
time go away and their 1995 g4 was
forced right we talked about this yeah
Queeny six queens you six the things
inducing g4 is good for black because it
weakens yeah whites weakens the king
chief Forza target you can take on e3
after after something like Queen G's
where you take e3 the Queen can't take
so you're gonna have to double your palm
so maybe you do take what the Queen just
sacrifice the pawn is like okay that's a
bad options but no but again it just did
I mean now it's gonna be a time scramble
Oh for the ages
whoa what a way to hold on this is
best defense is a good offense let's
analyze this and show the threat the
point is that Bishop takes you take e6
and the knight hangs at the end of the
line so Aronian wins his piece back what
a move and if you take not only are you
removing the idea that you get my queen
but I take right back and probably your
position just falls apart huh what a
move with nice e5 and only 18 seconds
this is where you could have used the
time on the clock right right now
lavon's up 47 40 seconds he was from
down two minutes any and he's probably
he's probably gonna go to convert here I
mean as we watch the time scramble come
to a close it just a five game lead for
the Armenian headed into the
three-minute is not where all the rest
of Arusha wanted to be thanks Captain
Obvious Dan again Oh pin Knight no gonna
convert one second two seconds gonna
trade on c8 up a pawn in the end game
super rough all the rezident a smile
maybe to lighten the mood I've heard
that if you force a smile it can send
endorphins and through your body even
though you don't actually feel happy
I've been trying that for a while the
pills work that doesn't seem to work I
just heard them when you smile the whole
world stops and stares for a while Oh
Thank You Burt oh wow so he's got a go
night see forward to try to win his
eighth but no I think we'll Vaughn
converse this one living on the
increment is all the Reza yeah this
doesn't look good as he Samko been
making a good point that Bishop II won
was better than Bishop f6 to get that a
five pawn yeah but before was possible
there I don't know that was really a
saving grace to be honest and Aronian
wins with it he takes a five game lead
into the three-minute portion we have
lots of action ahead of course 33
minutes 60 minutes of three-minute 30
minutes of one minute more matches after
that so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
eight of the most elite chess960 players
on the planet are set to clash in the
feed a world Fisher random Chess
Championship quarterfinals
beginning October 4th and ending October
6th played exclusively on chess calm
it's a game where creativity is king and
memorization is impossible and only one
player will earn the right to call
themselves the king of Fisher random
Vladimir Pharaoh say o ali reza perugia
wesley so Fabiano Caruana Peter Svidler
Yan de pomme neo she fitted Gujarati and
Hikaru Nakamura these players will take
center stage as they attempt to outwit
and outclass each other in a chess
variant that many consider to be the
game in its purest form the feet a world
Fisher random Chess Championship
quarterfinals will be an event like no
other with over 350,000 dollars in
prizes up for grabs it is the biggest
prize fund for any event in online chess
history will you tune in to witness who
moves on from the quarterfinals to join
Magnus Carlsen and Oslo tune in on the
first weekend of October on chest comm
TV and twitch.tv slash chess it's the
feed a world Fisher random Chess
Championship organized by June Deus and
chess calm
and as the 2019 speed chess championship
continues a little bit of a preview for
everyone in terms of what's to come
after the speech s championship
doubleheader today we will have the
official random World Chess Championship
qualifier drawing the set of you see
here go ahead give a little preview of
what what the what's under these pawns
here I don't even know which pawns which
let's blow this one let's bring it up Oh
Vidya NVIDIA Gujarati so gonna be kind
of fun here to make a random drawing
where grandmaster Robert Haas and I will
help determine the pairings Kali Reza
firoozeh will be random you will have
different camera angles to confirm and
provide security some transparency in
the process we're looking forward to it
let's remind everybody of the eight
players that will have their faces put
on pawns so that we can draw them there
they are I can't wait to see what
first-round match-ups we have all of
that action is coming to you tomorrow is
October 4th but today we still have a
lot of chess action to go Levon Aronian
ollie Reza Ferruccio a 5 game lead for
the favourite obviously the daily
question from a couple days ago was
about who as an underdog had the best
chance all he'd rezident won that vote
right now he's got a lot to prove let's
remind everybody of the daily question
from today because we have a couple
Twitter responses before the
three-minute takes off Robert we give
everyone a chance to vote Ollie Reza
made his way into the SCC via qualifier
so what are some other qualifiers we can
have community here we go once you go
ahead and read this one the bullet chess
championship of course so that speedy
and unknown chess players have the
chance to play a stronger and well-known
online tournament that is Francisco Jose
and he just wants bortnik strong that's
what I think he wants and ramesh says
country-wise championship then
championship of Champions that's a thing
that's actually been discussed because
we have such a growing international
community um one of the fun facts that
you may not know is that Creek or who's
the face of really chess calm in which
one jiggy's right he lives in Brazil
he's actually already run his own speech
has Championships in Portuguese and
we've had other events similar that
schooler sort of call him the satellite
SCC so that's that's an interesting way
that we might turn this whole thing into
a year-round endeavor to give give more
opportunity
so anyway cool stuff if you got any
other ideas throw them at us on Twitter
use the hashtag speech s you can vote I
believe via the twitch extension pole
here you can also just give us an
opinion in chat maybe we'll read it but
right now the games were about to begin
and we're gonna read the chessboard here
because we have liftoff into the
three-minute portion and all the rest
gets the white piece in this one and he
needs to win it I mean yes down five
games 72 we know that both nvl and
Yonkers up Duda came back from five four
or five point deficits earlier in the
SEC just last month and Duda beat a nice
carry and vo beat ye but against Levon
Aronian
I don't know being down five games
chuff-chuff not right for those of you
who may have forgotten Levon Aronian
made it all the way to the semi finals
last year in the speech Chess
Championship before ultimately being
outed by the eventual champion Hikaru
Nakamura so Levon Aronian is pretty good
as we keep saying pretty good at chess
he's pretty good at he's being a great
dad to his dog panchak panchak is anyway
Levon Aronian obviously very very good
at what he does and a experienced
competitor in the SEC his opponent on
the other hand only reza firoozeh this
is the first main SEC he's ever been in
and right now time to turn things around
yeah and he needs to just start winning
immediately and right now he's gonna
kind of the good position to try to
fight for a win and why do I say that
look at the hanging pawns what are
hanging pawns C 5 and D 5 they don't
protect each other they are reasonably
well advanced but anytime you push one
say he pushed up on a d4 you give away
all of the squares that it currently was
holding efore and c4 so that's why Levon
went for a 5 a 4 to break open the
Queen's out for his rook on 8th the
white rook is not on the a file so that
gives black some counter play on the
Queen side yeah and you highlight the
storyline of this position well write
the hanging pawns and what happens with
them will be the key point white wants
to poke and prod at those things that's
why I move like 91 was played not just
to open the bishop but maybe a maneuver
here because again if you can force them
forward as Roberts saying they only get
weaker they become more targetable I
think that's a word
so Bishop g5 played threatening in a lot
of positions to just go brute force
right remove the knight and win the
pollen but it's good works on
eight because in some of those lines
with the rook on the eight if you take
on f6 take with my Bishop e2 falls and
that could be a good news for LaVon
least a good opportunity for him to just
try to hold the position but you're
right right now Bishop takes f6 5 Bishop
takes d5 is a very big threat just
winning upon yeah and the threat is on
the board especially because there's
already a double attack right now with
the bishop on b7 so the von has
something to think about here something
to chew on
he's also in that he's also down 50
seconds in the pot yeah so if you were
looking for a tempo changing game right
switch of directions the winning the
first game in the three minute portion
might be huge and Levon Aronian right
now down on the town the clock yeah and
well he's a lot to figure out here
because you can play moves like rook to
b8 but that's met perhaps by simply
capturing on f6 and d5 still hangs and
an issue in any of these end games is if
you lose d5 then Lucy five to four on
three but I was gonna say maybe one of
the key points that holds it down for a
ronin is you do have e to hanging in
some positions right now anyway right so
there's a little bit to be figured out
okay ferruginous going for it okay we're
gonna see apparently he doesn't care
about the e to pawn in the line I just
highlighted well there's some background
checkmate so if you take on d5 I'll take
with my rook and here we'll see this
happen rook D takes e5 such that back
rank made exist but the a to pawn but
that's the key point as you said right a
to not capture ball everyone because of
that threat of rook c8 oh we sink
instead of g6 he could have played for B
to e8 and he was a missed opportunity
Oh a tempo on the night and this pawn
here now nice he - holds it all together
though so maybe it was okay it looks
like a very weird move to play but
you're right yeah seems to hold so Olly
Reza up upon what he needs is a victory
though the bishop is the better minor
piece of the - yep um but the a two
pawns the better a pawn of the tube
because there's only one yeah I actually
think that Holly rice I should slow play
as in man do anything to Jurassic rookie
one's good like that put that rook on E
- yeah rook a 7 rookie - it's still hard
to see progress for
right how do you get this pawn pushing
note that the bishop on f6 just such a
thorn in your shoe preventing you from
putting a rook on a1 and just pushing so
um
he's put the 9 and c4 then he might
eventually try to get it to square like
d5 or something like that you just need
to start just poking and prodding make
some threats there's on e4 okay four to
c5 again Robert inadvertently giving
great Grandmaster advice every would
maybe five and ninety eight Oh missed it
he missed it Aronian blundered that you
have to go for get see it oh he does see
it okay Knight at rook a six holds holds
the bishop but what I was gonna say is
Robert giving it invert an advice there
a centralized Knight is what regardless
of where it goes is the way you combat
the better minor piece so I'll address
it did everything he could to eventually
improve that night and bring it to some
better square so good for him
yeah now the night went from d2 up to e8
what do you get for that promotion
nothing it's kind of like you get a king
across the board in checkers or
something but wait maybe actually in
that case you actually do get wait what
hang in checkers extra you can't you get
a million checkers yeah and then goes
back then you go backwards you get a
triple King what happens if you get to
the back check on that what happens
rockers I'm just gonna take a sip of
this here Joe to be five I got a fact
check I think come in here interesting
data coming you must go east seven at
some point yo because of like captioning
of seven you protect f2 time scrambles
on for the first time all the resin
flexing on the clock this is what the
people have been waiting to see now we
got no not yet okay I'm really I'm
really curious about this I want to know
the answer fact check on checkers you
get you know do any this this kind of
thing is not in my job description this
is what you want from me in the future
we need to talk about it we need to talk
about okay so Wikipedia pop-culture
references okay well we'll add that
battleship win the live chess server go
sound okay it's a lot of good all right
well okay
Livan event
actually trades f7 for eight - but I
think this improves all the Reza's
chances yeah though this new pin is kind
of annoying I did agree totally agree
that okay it's because the pawns all
come to one side of the board that we
think that that might be good for the
night to help maneuver the bishop but
and they're just so many check mending
nets with like 96 to g5 gaming 90/65 try
to put something on h7 you can also
maybe try to poke it the Jeep on if the
knight comes to other squares whether
it's f4 e7 I just didn't figure out how
to get there that's the problem maybe
you unpin with King h3 coming in then f4
I kind of like King h3 because if you a
traded Knight takes f8 hit g6 go for it
when I say now she's six bait yup not to
find it nasty yeah he missed it huge
missed opportunity because he doesn't
win this game that's the kind of thing
that comes back and we will show it for
those of you who didn't calculate it as
quickly in your head will back this
thing up but I think that was a win yeah
I think he missed it oh my gosh that's
the game that all heroes in needs to
happen the kid needs a break to keep
this match close and drawing this would
not be that okay but he still has
chances here still has chances to win
yeah you can play this on forever yep so
where's you know f4 at some point in the
Charlie yeah if you get you go f4 and
press work on b6 and go out for f5
that's one of the ideas here another
idea is going at some moment Knight f7
check and rewrite that night he's trying
and he's like what did I do
oh I just lost it I lost it oh my gosh
all he Reza lost it and it wasn't even
like a swindle by the Von rook me too
was a legitimate offer because of the
trade will back this thing up on the
analysis board real quick and show
everybody what happened what a
heartbreaker for the kid here this move
rook b2 was not a trolling move by Levon
the bishop protects it right and so
Aronian just offering a trade to try to
get drawing chances and Farouk just
complete
he blunders the rook now for those of
you who wanted to see the mate earlier
back in the position with both pieces on
the board right here instead of the move
Knight g5 Knight to f8 threatening rook
takes g6 mate because of this the rook
can be sacrificed this is the key thing
all he reza missed Knight if fate would
have been I think just lights out how do
you stop rook takes you six because if
you play rook a six take your rook on a
six and now H sevens me up so Knight f8
has dual there's no way to deal with
both g6 and h7 as jul threatened mates
both of them protected by the knight oh
my gosh dude what a heartbreak what a
turnaround what a game that's like
that's a six game lead now for Levon
Aronian Olli Reza is on full tilt here
yeah you got a feel for him because he
played a nice game there right and he
was up upon yep he traded the a pawn for
the F pawn and then unfortunate for me
hung a rook in an game where only he
could press forever Wow Levon is so
serious here I don't think I don't know
how closely he follows our daily
question Twitter polls from day one
right did he know that firuzan was voted
as the most likely to upset obviously we
know LaVon really likes the speeches
championship he said he said that he
wants to maybe get back to the
semi-finals I don't know what motivation
LaVon needed today Robert but is this as
good as we've seen him play in his
features championship it's fantastic yes
yeah and he's won six games in a row six
games in a row and and it started when
he was up 3-2 and he won that game where
he sacrificed the pawn and they always
just forgot so he's getting checkmated
you know he's a bad position in that
point anyway but it seems like all the
rest is missing many things staying
right he is such a tactical wizard but
he's just not showing his best stuff and
I think the real reason why is not
because I'll racism anything
particularly wrong it's because LaVon is
so strong it's so tricky and I know
everyone is you know is used to seeing
Alireza play online and I say you know
he's so tactical all this but LaVon is
that and a little bit more right so
that's the real issue right now
ya know I mean he he's up against a very
very strong player a very very strong
competitor and we have a little bit of a
visit there from Fabiano Caruana and
valor Pharaoh say of the ghosts
of the future for sure random pass I
love that this came to say hello that's
why they pay me what happens when you're
running so many shows just calm the
amount of events were doing these days
right when you're trying to prepare for
a major event the first ever world
championship ever been a part of while
running the speeches championship our
producers are hard at work so also
lavon's blitz rating is now 31 32 he's
getting really high up there yeah he's
uh he's higher rated than Purusha by a
hundred points he's been stealing all of
Virgil rating so we'll see if Levon can
keep up that trend right now with the
white pieces here there's a lot of
pressure on d6 and it's Bishop on h4 it
looks excellent but look at Levon she
says you know I don't want to trade
things off I don't wanna liquidate I
don't open up squares for black I just
want the pressure baby i'ma sit in the
position yeah and you can never take on
e5 twice because look at that diagonal
look where the Queen situated look where
the rook um being situated so anytime
you try to take on e5 too many times
you're opening up a diagonal for you to
lose material on that's a great point
Bishop e7 trying to fix that problem so
that you could take and keep control
excuse me don't move your bishop like a
knight move your Bishop like a Bishop e6
played now to prevent that yep and this
a pawn is strong but advancing it
allowed I was gonna say allows the
knight back right gives up control we
have six square the problem is where's
the night going after f6 the e4 is well
covered and I like Levon decision not to
take on b5 love you would say oh I can
take this Bishop off the board for my
knight but the knight c3 covers that e4
square whereas the bischmann because I
was not really doing anything in
particular
and now h5 played okay what what's
what's the next on the move okay
he wanted to check perhaps so Levon said
no thank you I'm wondering where the
rook goes from a3 what one of the
obvious ideas you over protect the
knight here for tactics but I wonder if
he has more ambitions in mind I'm not
sure obviously I not a scientist I just
stated a you're not holiday in it but
you like that song by Coldplay
absolutely okay just fantastic
just want to make sure well this
position just doesn't look fun for black
yeah it's hard for black to find moves
he's also down on the clock by about 30
seconds here currently so it's gonna be
three isn't about g3 g3 makes a lot of
sense is that you know you don't play
with a g3 because you think what the H
file
uh-oh what's a connection issues it's
not just for them for all of us know
we're all back and now we're back and
we're back again somewhere I thought you
wouldn't go with that what they're gonna
do the song I've seen the replacements I
was I was actually gonna go back streets
back Wow all right six b5 ro takes b5
followed by Knight takes d5 sac the
exchange it's probably not that great
but it looks pretty I can't tell what's
going on right here with the lag Levon
Aronian z-- connection way worse
currently then okay now he's back seems
like our entire server had a glitch
there so we got about 45,000 people
online who all just experienced a bit of
a Twilight Zone visit there so but but
we're back no real problems well there's
some problems here for fruga besides the
score look at this position yeah he's
nuts LaVon sacrifices in exchange he's
taking two pawns for this this is the
Armenian chess school at its best
sacking exchanges sacking exchanges and
then using it for the rook on b6 this is
a target this is a target this is a
target right it's the Oprah of targets
finding them all
Ruby 7 yeah looking nicely forward to
protecting them a 5-pound would be six
get out of my house queen east 7 d6 does
somebody say seven-game lead seven-game
lead thank you
I say answering that redundant question
and making me look like a fool
it's not the first time sorry don't be
sad those past pawns are dashboards are
made to be pushed
wowzers wowzers wowzers a seven-game
lead is on the way EA Queen is one way
to do it followed by D seven and G 6 is
falling where do he goes Queen takes g6
first and then goes D 7 because you know
how many times you've done that a few
times today right that would be
unnecessary though and here G six
falling is enough for all the Reza to uh
thrown the towel throw in the towel or
not just not not the best day currently
for the young man from Iran doing his
best a great day for feet a master
approach and playing guess the move with
nine out of 21 right there first place
congratulations not bad
keep improving that can you play him in
that right let's get that thing about
50% but we got a lot of people here
thanks for being here regardless of
where you choose to be watching today
whether it's just outcome TV twitch.tv
slash chess or anywhere else in the
world let's remind you of more reasons
to hit that purple follow button or if
you're watching it on chest comm go
ahead take that journey to twitch you
can come back well welcome you back you
know it's okay I know some of you were
watching on the embed right now I see
you in your chair put the cat down click
on the player and go hit that purple
follow button above the player you're
scaring them yeah I know somebody just
said Oh somebody literally somebody just
want the cat down wondered they put the
cat down they put the cat down the feed
HS dot-com grande Swiss coming up as our
next major event after the feed a fish
world fish a random quarterfinals this
weekend
lots of good stuff and then of course we
have the fish of random World Chess
Championship in Norway so 2019 the year
of chess events as it would be pretty
sure notion psalmist's predicted that
what my team will be the year of chess
events I claim I don't know I love the
voice I love the voice TV show both
later yep here we see the position where
Y is experienced on the queenside with a
for the night I'm b7 that is not a happy
night not a heavy you don't tend to want
your night Sydney to be sitting there
but the good news for black what is the
good news for black there are good
things in this position for black this
could be all there
a chance to strike oh we have said that
before we did and we said it before
because it it was it was right until the
rook fell you know but no he's he's
better here as white for sure I guess
the one thing for black is white lacks
the next move right where's the where's
the next breakthrough coming yeah do you
slow play it a five-night a for Knight
b6 that looks like a plan a pretty good
one actually now that you're protecting
e4 you can free this Knight of his
duties yep
I've been a lot the one thing you have
to be concerned about is if you move the
knight from c3 some kind of defy push
because black really lacks space and d5
is not possible thanks to the clamp
efore c4 Knight c3 Queen on b3 all
stopping that push so that's what black
would like to accomplish and here was b5
to make sure the d5 score is permanently
White's this is bad look at that
when I fade the bishop I need to be so
much better says ooh b6 threatens b7
yeah that's remember in the last game
where Yvonne had that past epon
protected by deep on opponent b6 is
pretty happy 94 nice try for some
counter play me you might even see c5
despite the fact that d5 becomes a
permanent weakness just to try to
reinforce this Knight okay he doesn't do
it smart is he gonna try to flip
something to the Kings side as we've
seen him do and tricky ways before I
guess d4 is hanging at the moment or the
good thing I'm pointing at f1 was to
attack it and there's no does it but
again the consequence of this as we said
is d5 is weak and what white really
wanted to do with some of our trade the
g3 knife or the f6 Knight and then just
plug the knight on d5 but this is
definitely going to be a good trade
regardless and the 94 looks great it's
centralized its well-protected but it's
not attacking anything doesn't have a
targets to exploit so right now it just
seems like white is pressing forward
there's even a threat nicely sevinor's
win a6 though then those two pawns are
salted yeah an i7 is certainly a
possibility and maybe he's gonna maybe
sack the exchange again really don't
want to I mean you might have to write
this isn't the classic Tigran Petrosian
Armenian chess school exchange sack this
is I
want to lose a six and in the game right
so a few an Icee seven can black try
Queen d7 and say alright go ahead and
try to steal my a6 pawn but this might
happen I think is happening I think I
think the exchange sac is borderline
necessary here for black yeah but
doesn't feel no and look at all the rest
on the clock here a monk a s in the in
the chess TV chest says all the resident
looks defeated but I think he's perking
up now I think he's broken up he just
needs to get a win got to get a win and
this could be the game well just put
that over come b1 yep bring it to the B
file b8 square upon a6 is still a target
you don't air up in exchange you have a
look at LaVon defending yeah there's no
clear breakthrough yet he has a pawn for
the exchange now mm-hmm oh man but now
this is just tough that's a no I move
for black to meet because you cannot
allow Knight c3 to d5 you just cannot
allow that night to go forward to Knight
62 is a movie don't want to play because
you're getting rid of your best piece
for the night that it was not planned
what is this boys his plan he wants b4
to guard e5 but then just gonna trade on
d5 anyway seems possibly right he goes
for it we're gonna find out so 95 here
looks very good mm-hmm the one thing the
LaVon is going for as if the trade
happens and you take with the C pawn I
am primed to push right right but we're
ready stay with the e pawn rook b3
interesting it's a waiting move what's
the plan here LaVon pulled up his
sleeves and sat up they need to make
those st. Louis Chess Club polos a
little more fitted there he's fold them
up like they're too long affecting his
nails maybe he doesn't know his proper
size possible depends on the make right
shoot European fits - okay American fits
Bishop g5 here watch this Bishop e5 okay
Bishop g7 you take on f6
to come before Oh fork town f6 and c7
it's coming and in ferocious got to keep
up on the clock
he's well a herdsman coming from Chad I
agree with them 95 now and just trade it
there it is here it is this is a game to
convert this is a game to convert if
you're Olly Reza get on the board keep
this thing closed we talked earlier
about lavash sensation I'll say that
okay he the other motivation he has to
keep building on this lead is Olly
recive will be the favorite of bullet I
don't care what smarter chess says uh
how big of a favorite we'll find out but
I think that lavon's focus here
I mean remains high with a seven-game
leave because he knows that that will
likely see see a dent there from Olli
Reza soon yeah this game take on c7 by
Queen B 7 there is no Queen a5 a6 is
falling now this this has to be a game
that all the resident wins look at the
clock he's actually up on the clock now
for the first time in a very long time
last-ditch effort is e4 III by Aronian
he's going for it all the residue she
should just calculate make sure it's not
good even a 6
III rookie 1 is good enough that looks
actually very strong there is there's
taken Queen h4 but I don't think it does
anything okay this also yeah it rings a
second Queen to the game get one little
check here and there but my king can
always run away especially cuz my
broker's on b1 just King takes f2 yeah
just don't even allow it take and backup
and put the King on h1 it's over whoa
over thinks that a little bit okay Queen
and then check I mean just take and same
I should still be wouldn't you yeah you
just you need the knight to jump to e4
in one turn h8 Queen e7 I'm assuming
there's maid look at the ball and make
it as tricky as possible Queen h4 does
the job Queen f2 mate no as I made it
but the Queen's being traded I think was
good enough for me to resign and we have
the first victory for Ali Reza in more
than an hour
Wow spender it's been an hour since
since he got a victory if you're one of
the viewers just joining us it was a
two-two
score in this match before Levon Aronian
went on the run that just ended there
right there's no head no drawers no
drawers no cross let's get a stat check
on that how long have we had a match so
so far we've had a total of what's
what's the math score well it said well
games yeah 93 um 12 games with no draws
to start a match it's got to be getting
pretty close to the record if not there
so yeah it's actually unbelievable that
we've had no draws and I mean most the
games have not felt even close to draws
prior to this match ammonia's longest
win streak ever was five games so he
broke his own record there Tayyab nine
nine diamond member on chess calm and a
well-known chatter and the twitch
community as well just one the guests
the move shoutout to that if you want to
play guess the move click on the link
that that will be provided here soon
one of our awesomely helpful mods and
head over to chess calm and try to guess
the moves before the players play them
themselves
test your chest knowledge well this
position we've seen many many many times
yeah I'm here the point not in this
match but in classical games right the
point is that black has the two bishops
but if you look at the bishops the
bishop on c8 often gets traded for the
bishop on d3 via some kind of Bishop a6
maneuver but the bishop on f6 doesn't
really have anywhere useful to go
because the pawn on d4 in the pawn on f4
you know that bishop has no life and
it's a big issue for black and turns to
how to get activity as I can go 95 by I
I mean the player with the white pieces
and just gain even more space if you
ever take me I take with the F pawn and
double my pawns and then just start
throwing my stuff forward so it's a
pretty easy position to play for white
but I like what black is done just
saying okay I've not taken before until
I'm ready to take over the a file and
here Y can just try to challenge that
rook rook b3 is always an option but he
plays better than my last suggestion is
95 these are positions that only got a
cops kick in love with a hair dude to
change change the world the bishop on b7
it's just this is it reminds me it's the
d4 version of the French let me create a
bad positional structure so I can grovel
for
and well look at this bishop h5 going
tactical right away f7 and I think this
is a bad bullets opening to choose
especially after you just got a win so
yes hard for me to be nicer about this
position I'm sorry
you can't play something that gives you
a legitimate chance right right yeah
this is just one of those lines
especially it gets Aronian where he goes
this stuff you know and they takes g6
then other Knight to e5 somebody that
looks this is probably better he's good
95 next yeah with tempo on the Queen
followed by a sacrifice on g6 if you're
into it 95 maybe Queen e8 and he doesn't
sack because he still just better right
you've got a great night versus a
Franken Bishop yeah he's smart yeah so
he sits tight I would sack cuz I mean
this makes sense right I mean faroush is
best chances to trade here and as I said
grovel for a draw with the bad bishop
you're right near 100% rub any rook
trade benefits white because blacks only
chances are coming down the a 5ml yep
this is the key for black holding the
whole position is to keep pressure on
the a file so Brooke B 3 tries to tries
to change that I think we might see our
first draw I think there might be some
kind of rookie right as we write as we
made the call to action that we've had
12 straight games with no draws yeah
because at some point I think black and
/ ok - Andrew back to a3 and I don't
know how white exactly makes progress
lavon's trying so credit em good but now
with Bishop d3 this here's his idea he
wants to eventually challenge the a file
and the Queen can never leave because
then Bishop takes g6 will happen right
so he's gonna play Queen to c3 then put
the rook on a1 simplify things on the a
file and just grind through this angle
but if all the Queens and rooks are off
then it will likely be a draw because
there's no real way for White's a broken
ya fair right Eve as bad as the bishop
is there's no way to break through
that's a bad it's a bad bishop
it's a bad bishop I don't think even a
mother could love that bishop yeah that
is a bad bishop have a queen a4 here oh
now you're talking
Queen a4 that's a pig bishop he finds it
so Brooke be whining rookie three is
probably smart rook b1 are we gonna get
that first peaceful result of the day
what I want is Queen B - Bishop C -
moved the rug Queen B once a kanji
that's what I work you want it all in
you want I want it all I want to know
how about 966 there's rush 66 to file ah
he might be preparing it look out look
out I'm looking clean ch3 he's taking
advantage of the fact that he can sit
tight right he's in control of all the
cars being Levon Aronian here uh Bashir
would be seven is so sad so sad that's a
bad sign that you played okay six here
comes g5 and this queen is gonna work it
with no diggity to the H file here goes
g5 gonna bag up that W yep but g5
applause Bishop takes e5 which I'm not
sure you're still just better though is
why that's a nice move if takes you ever
you take with the F pawn and the Queen
lands on h6 yeah the eagle has landed
here this is this is a such a tough
position for black so do you reroute now
a bishop see - there it is
and if Brooke it's you've queen b1 oh
gosh Queen on play Queen B one and then
you're really feeling sac you're gonna
take with the knight take with the
Bishop do you take it right now okay get
the rook out for again patients patient
it's a virtue but I wasn't being
virtuous Bishop b3 he's he's pointing
out the fact that black it's like a good
dictator right just continue the abuse
oh boy oh it wasn't being specific I'm
just saying that's what that people do
and he's just dictating the position he
can play ninety seven if he wants at
some point he can do over time and
everyone mom Jarvan g5 94 96 check you
know just like China g5 night you for
night f6 Jack I like that too so what f5
here it goes the breakthrough is on the
cool okay I was gonna say the Queen's
gonna come back to c8 this also works oh
oh can you take on no you can't take on
g6 cuz they made you take f7 Queen da
he's sacrificing c2 for e d8 the mating
net is real yep oh it hurts taking
advantage of the Queen cutting herself
off from the defense what a move he pops
his collar
gone brush his shoulder off a roni in
his playing chest to gone brush your
shoulder off I wasn't gonna say the
radar
burst your shoulder off whoa Bishop d7 I
don't understand well if you take it
just take it that's a good idea
he took it f6 f6 looks like it does the
trick
by the way Queen h4 threatens me cuz the
knight guards the escape square
oh so innocent made it run away he
should have done that first yeah I think
Queen h4 was even better than f6 but
he's gonna win yeah that was nice steak
sauce did
steak sauce my dude steaks awesome I did
I hope your sons are watching that steak
sauce my did by Levon Aronian
Queen h4 we need Queen uh war threatens
quit yeah but quench for was your idea
so I wanted to support it yeah Wow the
31 that was a gamer that was a game they
just you're so right though that opening
choice was really bad not really really
bad you just don't want to get yourself
in a situation where you're groveling
for a draw from move 10 yeah and you
have no real chance to play for more and
LeBron is cruising right now
still no draws do we do no draws we're
smart yeah we're smarter chess by the
way and that last game national master
jbd 735 got 25 out of 47 that's more
than 50% there you go J BD leapfrogging
Tay up 99 and guess the move follow the
games live at chess calm and play guess
the move have some fun wow what a game
right there the longest draw streak
total was 20 games and go Nina Daniela
the longest no draw streak total yeah
we're about the sec WS CC that's so
great that's also amazing yeah that's 20
straight games yeah of no draws that's
nuts
that's nuts but now I'm very curious of
the sec yep
smart chess not being so smart now he's
need fun master Mike the original stat
guy stat boy behind this smart chest in
the chat has putting me to work man this
is what a great game that was though by
the way yeah I mean I know it was not
the best opening choice for
Rezo and we were rightfully a little
critical but um oh but that was nuts
Sam Copeland says JBD is the chest comm
2018 daily Chess Champion by the way
really Wow no wonder guessing the much
daily chess champion coming through
right yeah trying to add another title
to guess the other champion guess the
move champion huh
so waiting with a 95 well I've seen
better but that's pretty good sure you
know what how would be better if the men
f3 and a 98 were traded that's how it'd
be better yeah if you take off these two
guys this is a night that you can write
home to mom and dad about this is this
is the good stuff right here
Purusha in control of this one looking
to bounce back bring this thing back to
six games 26 minutes left in the three
minutes plus one second increment
portion for those who don't speak chess
lingo time control that's what that
means three minutes plus one second
increment is what we're seeing here yeah
and this is about a four now now the
b-pawn is pinned and was like a four it
seems reasonable okay Brooke b1 I like I
said I'm not a bad idea either
you heard me clamoring for a four but
the reason why I like a four is I will
take it what you want I would take with
the C pawn and then push my a pawn I was
trying to get an awesome okay I'll back
this thing up and show everybody what
what Robert wanted you play a four the
main difference is you take take and
then a five yeah okay I agree that did
seem a little more logical but he takes
of six parting with the brilliant night
for the chance to swing things to the
Kings side for an attack honestly I
don't like it you don't like it I just I
feel like the advantage might be
slipping here it's still better for
white but the dominance that once was
right if we back this thing up just a
few moves ago where you asked me how do
I like that night well you like it on
the board I like it on the board better
than here f5 a dynamic defensive move I
like it you're on allowing Knight h4
with the clamp and again I'm not denying
these are obviously two very strong
grandmasters and white is better but
look at the position if it opens up the
Brooke doesn't feel as awkward anymore I
I don't like it yeah blacks king's
nothing unsafe and you don't take on e4
here and then put your net on d4 and the
94 stop your whole plan of nine at five
yep
so here comes Queens five maybe f4 is
gonna follow suit but f4 doesn't
actually there's no knockout punch and I
think that f4 it might help black when
you take e.t except for your rook and
swing over the Kings side yeah so this
has been very smart defensive play by
Levon Aronian yeah this is the the
highest levels of speed chess right in
the speeches chamber these guys play
such good games with no time on the
clock the fact that he's defending this
but also it's a sign of Purusha just
letting it slip h6 has a move in it I
don't know if I would ever consider it
but it's good yeah that's probably going
good just guarding g5 if Knight f5
you'll trade and put the Queen on f6
right black is completely defended the
advantage has gone here for white really
interesting move yeah because I was
thinking how can i play d5 or something
like that but they'd open up some more
files and things like that for the white
attack whereas Jason's calm yeah and it
also stops anything going going here
with a perpetual and with an edge on the
clock maybe this thing turns around
completely you still haven't had a draw
if you're just joining us 13 straight
decisive games in this match yeah I was
in Queen f6 to the h6 but I really like
h6 more
and now rook III to g3 is an idea of
course so Brooke c3 so ah rookie
now if you'll rookie 3 there's some kind
of rook c1 check yeah it takes up to
maybe queen of four of them rook g3x
yeah but yeah there's a lot going on
here that's actually a lot to calculate
though it's done which is bad for
firoozeh because a lot of time oh he did
it he's no I was gonna say it's not so
simple because let's look at the line of
here UNH's the King first and part of
the reason everyone is cuz if you had
given check and taken first now the
check and that Queen enters with Tempe
and that kind of changes the attack so
King f8 runs that allows for who should
have fixed the bad night Queen f4 here
others g4 rook see one first and then
queen up for you g3 enough for white and
both lines
even so rook c1 king up queen of for
chiii Queen back oh I like it right you
take shake and bake and f2 is falling so
he's cooking g2 I guess but yeah you
still have a yeah bucks well yeah he's
gonna consider my danfous rook C to send
your nice pin ah another way to do it
right
ever move that night we got bait and I
wonder if black just try play from
within ninety six I need to to do the
same thing getting the Queen's off the
board f2 is a problem that's a huge raw
black is in complete control of this
game the time scramble will be close to
equal though and this is where a roni
will have to continue to prove his worth
right yep and he can go 90 to check
tonight back to f4 or feats like trying
to make a draw or like this rook c1
Brooksie - but he wants more oh my gosh
they bought so much more King g3 he's
Bob Barker Inc yeah that's take the
whole thing check and put it on f6
anymore put on g7 almost it so ah check
and go to g7 or f5 I love that he'll
repeat it I think he'll find it the
second time around
he also he's gaining some time trouble
oh no no first peaceful results it
happened I'm very upset
oh man I'm surprised the Vaughn didn't
push that on yeah I guess he figured
that you know you pushed too much maybe
he could get himself in some trouble but
it looks very nice yeah look very good
so we have another little g3 Bishop g2
yep situation going on here the f99
recovering takes back the crown from JBD
735 and guess the move oh 22 out of 43
for teh up 9 9 22 out of 54 JBD Davey
Davey chess champion on sometimes less
those two guys were throwing at it
they're not throwing at it that would be
like throwing something to the wall it'd
be like throwing down okay I'm over this
hammer it's almost like bringing on
y'all just got served right whatever
happened to that you actually did that
live thanks awesome I did know we did
that once
steak sauce but it no not again no say
it I know look at those look at those
dance and heads having a party
Oh only one of the most things having a
party right one of them is on top but
they're creating them you know they're
working together to create a fish like
you know like that scene from Fantasia
we're all in other words if Holly resin
goes on a winning streak we'll get the
fish yeah that's right if all that
really goes on a winning streak if we
stay flat here we're gonna be seeing a
flat lining from the bottom but there
you go well interesting stuff here today
I think that Levon Aronian is sending a
message to a degree right now obviously
we know bullet is ahead and if all the
Reznick an get this thing even just a
little bit closer right does he does he
find a way to finish the 3-meter portion
with a couple of victories what do you
think the range needs to be for him to
realistically have a chance and bullet
to come back for agreed yeah anything
more than four I think it's out of reach
because LaVon is quite a talented bullet
player yeah he's got stable internet
connection and we've seen it live on
play many times and one of the times was
that the bullet Chess Championship but
he was into the hotel hotel lobby with a
horrible internet connection because
he's playing the Bundesliga right that
so he was a really bad connection he's
playing Maxine with Sheila Grove yeah
number didn't work out very well and AH
no draws 19 games in a row was yesterday
Nakamura broke two days ago I'm losing
track of time two days ago
yeah Wow jinx you owe me a coke now you
I just jinxed you night at four d3 is
gonna fall again I think Aronian has
shown a little something in terms of
prep and I wonder if he just played the
English as part of features this weapon
regularly and his over the board
repertoire yeah but I wonder if you
specifically was like you know I really
feel like this is my opportunity some
different tricky move orders right
that's where experience really pays off
right a lot of times these young players
reached can reach these levels a lot of
talent a lot a lot of great vision
calculation but no matter how good you
are there's still experience that takes
time to get and I think sometimes these
sort of obscure move orders can and
honestly is move 15 and this looks like
why she's clearly better
yeah with this dealing with this it's
not all an insult to a racer but it's
something you mentioned earlier about
how the flexibility that are running in
the showed has put other isn't he
situation where he needs the fun
accurate movement o'clock because of it
yep the clock situation is clearly in
favor lafawn he rookie to here okay
that's a pretty good decision at this
point almost necessary
I still think it'll take enough six take
up six if the Queen takes we win the
Palmer tempo oh okay
pawn takes now you've got long-term
positional problems I mean ninety six
might scoop the pawn magic six wins the
pawn anyway with tempo and now that King
is open and look at the Queen site hello
McFly bueller bueller she won a full
Marty on me right nobody's playing over
there nobody's home I'm just calling
Mardi Gras
anyway no but seriously this is this has
just been a very very good performance
for Levon Aronian and something that all
the rest will learn from regardless of
what happens in Bullitt because the
Blitz has been dominated by the Armenian
no matter what the final score is at the
end of the day which also indicates that
it's been dominated by yep
rookie ones a nice move just trying to
say look at the Queen side your bishops
on c8 can't move we're gonna eat can't
move and if I get a piece of the final
rank oh here comes Knight d6 though you
can't even think about 97 to d5 to work
with I mean oh he likes it too and he's
also gonna take on e 2 now he's taking
you to next the night will come to d5 or
stay there for ya some sort of Meetup
honesty's a resigned to a position at
this point which is sad when it's move
18 and this was a first stage of the
game kind of lesson by Aronian I thought
Bishop e4 trapped the Queen when of
course does queen g4 h 3 h 5 but some
kind of queen might check and yeah there
should be four just I think checking
Bishop b5 it's F so that's oh he doesn't
go for it but he wants the pawn
he'll he'll take and then take his time
right because even with the mover up ba
these pieces have still not joined the
fight
yeah in 98 actually comes to mind
there's another possibility
trying to win that pawn with it oh wow
I think I'm guessing the move right in
this game first blunder of the match for
Levon Aronian and he's like still not
even dead loss as a rookie
oh my god is he gonna come back in this
look that was freaking nuts oh my gosh
oh my god that was this this is the
first blunder of the match that was
Levon Aronian and I don't know I'm sure
he's lost here he's in whenever so
amazing is that he could still win this
game I don't know dude he takes up six
and takes of seven like this isn't was a
situation he's got one page seven he's
got hairy that rook still is not doing
the fight if he takes before I'm picking
with the bishop nobody shoot me seven
check f3 that's what he'll play f3 king
of 2h 4 this is this is like I'm saying
that because of time forgot the position
like look at the situation right he
could still win this yeah time to take
the bishop Miko Bishop e2 King f2 you're
right you've got to do something like
that
there it is go back ok
I don't think I like that move so much
Wow ok but if all heroes it can
capitalize here talk about a momentum
shift yes it would be a huge moment in
the match at this led to some sort of
come back and look at a 4 this is
exactly what you do with the rook open
up line so ok it's done bishop c2 is
always c4 yeah and this comes here comes
firoozeh Chucky's gonna take up 7 with
check and then play 95
guarding in attacking at the same time
if you get G for g5 f 5 in very quickly
there are some outside chances to hold
this game but there's a little it's
having it quickly enough yeah well I
don't know eight seconds Knights are
tricky who would you like and bullet I
love the night because look the Knights
have beaten me before and he's got a
position I see so I like that for g5
let's go take over the dark squares one
second oh we barely got that off in time
okay just move the bishop
okay III allowing the check traded yeah
this is now I was not gypsy to for
firoozeh
ship si - oh my god White's gonna win
this oh my god with no time f5 I was an
absolute mistake just push it yeah he
should have trade him when he had the
chance here comes Knight f5 995 and I'd
be five might be five doesn't with tempo
but same things good
okay so III I think not if I was better
actually cuz you could have done here
alright too late Wendy man holding just
in time I think that if five was the
move was that ninety six check was six
oh my gosh six seconds I guess that pawn
can't push anymore which is the do push
king D to the pawn runs out of squares
oh my god it's looking at the players on
camera it's gonna be a draw which
somehow feels like a fair result yeah
given that one player blundered is Queen
as long as there's no like mouse slip
you know tactics here to lose the rook
if black wants to draw you can just take
on take either minor piece in any moment
but if you blunder a fork that's how
things go wrong okay he decides I'm not
even gonna risk risk the situation place
it out and we have a draw
wow that was how often does somebody
blunder a one move fork on f3 let's back
up real quick to the analysis board and
just show what happened there because
LaVon in complete control in this game
gonna try to back this thing up and
complete control on this game I have to
go so far back even see the blunder
right here this position has been over
for many moves just a horrible position
for the Queen the king the pieces on the
Queen side any other move King G to rook
t1 right instead Bishop takes d3 hangs a
fork
get your emotes out chess TV twitch TV
just but guess what
like who's better here right look at the
position just unreal unreal we just saw
a one move queen blunder a fork on f3
and yet white comes back in this game
instantly winning the Queen right back
absolutely bananas we continue here in
the speech Chess Championship on chess
calm if you're one of the eight thousand
viewers who's just
joining us hit the follow button the
biggest events in chess happened right
here we've got so many of them going on
right now and the speeches chairmanship
has been a thriller today guess what
right after this we have our Kimia
versus grishnack it's a doubleheader
today Russians throwing down young
Russian versus old blood all fighting
for pride of the motherland I was
waiting for you to finish because you
like that's a crazy ball everything the
light touches
Chuck Norris is the Russian Chuck
Christian sit back that's a quote I'm
not making it up but seriously this is
this has been an exciting match the
scoreboard reads with a seven-point
advantage for the Armenian but Olli Reza
Ferruccio known to the fans online as a
bullet beast and we still have the
entire bullet segment to come do you see
that comment by a vp b OT boat is
invented boat s gambit Aronian perfected
right who will they talk about in the
books from years to come but with the
queen blunder no seriously because the
whole point of the bonus game is a
blunder yeah Aronian just blundered the
queen for a borderline victory right
that's amazing seriously that was good
stuff well lavon's pretty solved with
the black piece in this game you know
after taking on before justperson ident
c5 then the d3 pawn is feeling some heat
the e4 pawn also and I think I like what
freesias done generally speaking about
trying to get rid there's not enough six
and take over the d5 square but here it
feels like potentially I move too slow
although actually you can take on f6 and
play 95 because nice c7 fork is
available in many variations he'll go up
gay doesn't defends it first he'll go
for good but he'll he'll go for kit the
the d5 square wants to go for kit on c7
and in chess we've referred to a fork as
a move that attacks two pieces at once
that is completely appropriate
referencing there you go the double
attack fork refers to exactly the
family-friendly type of forking yeah I'd
love some pasta so let's go with it
start with the Ford gave me the posture
all good Queen to b6 is coming followed
by Knight to d5
and
everybody's happy ok so instead we get
an end game the night's still coming to
d5 but they're just not enough pieces
left right you know you take enough six
you double the pawns not that big a deal
d4 is coming if you trade on f6 and
probably we're looking at our third
consecutive peaceful result so if you're
just joining us we had 13 straight
decisive games in this match and now
we've had two draws in a row and working
our way towards a third yep and maybe
those were 13 straight draws wouldn't it
be funny it would be a bad sign for all
the resident who needs more than a
peaceful result to make a comeback here
because he only has about two three
mini-games left with the time as such
the timer is at 8 minutes and 35 seconds
and counting down yep so he's got a
couple of these games left which maybe
makes him happy because he wants to get
the bullet but he needs a victory
somewhere only 8 minutes left in the
three-minute +1 second portion if you're
just joining us this is the middle
segment remind you real quick of the
speed chess championship format if
you're one of our new viewers this is
the most exciting event I would say in
chess but certainly an online chess it
is the the opportunity for the world's
elite to play in the speed chess
championship 90 minutes of 5-minute plus
1 second increment 1 second has added to
the clock on every move then you have 60
minutes of 3 plus 1 which is the segment
where now followed by bullet chess which
is yet to come so don't go anywhere
stick around hit the follow but we got a
lot a lot of chests left today and the
bonus amount of a pawn
right like in this position yeah but I
mean tonight it's coming at 5 the kind
of pawns you're happy about yeah but I'd
rather be able to pawn than down 1 ok
fair then I can go to e6 and into f4 of
rook d2 stuff is coming I'm not saying
white is lost as white certainly is not
even close to losing because there's a
lot of stuff with the rook b8 9 to 5
same idea kind of but knight b3 also
blocks the rooks gaze right so he wants
to bring the knight into a more useful
position but also keep the rook at bay
oh I missed that because now 966 now a
knight recheck that's a discovery and
wins the night so the knight has to back
up but here comes Roberts playing the
knight wants to make the long journey to
f4 maybe black and try for f5 at some
point - it's like you've many options
here
sixteen g5y nevermind he takes Kingi
five ah it's funny when you were first
talking about the pawn I thought it was
you know the UH King h6
rook b8 King G five main rook GA check
oh my god what a mate if King takes h4
g3 is checkmate that's how you beat
yourself yep right there don't don't
walk your King into a checkmate but and
again he goes back to b3 partly to keep
the idea of the rook not joining the
fight he's blocking the rooks gaze I
like it just from a practical
perspective just just to keep the
stranglehold over the position
especially as we now near time pressure
only 20 seconds for white 56 seconds for
black yeah bring that king up come bring
that came to g5 bring it up buttercup I
like it
why do you build me up you down best me
around
worst of all called me baby let's do it
though then I don't know five is where
you want to be and LaVon has actually
lost his threat of night
wait now Knight takes D six is a thing
yeah but rook any game and say yeah draw
right gone for 13 in a row only five
minutes remain here are the three minute
portion from a practical point of view
Purusha welcoming bullet at this point
he means the faster time control to have
a chance to get some more blunders out
of Aronian Aronian has made one blunder
today that I can count hang and he
didn't even lose the game crazy he's in
pretty on point
yeah all right well this f7 pawn it's in
some trouble here so king g6 just bring
the King up eight seconds for firoozeh
here we go whoa the check is on Knight
h6 check and then okay rook takes f6
first hits rookie six now efore okay the
only question is whether there's some
sort of outside meaning of six nice game
and now the draw you've got you've been
denied you've reacted very much I didn't
let out the yeah yeah you jump you know
a lot of people saw this or like it's
this is trouble this is trouble that's
only one pawn there
you lose that h-bond but only food the
pin and there's only two seconds though
for firoozeh but he you know he's a
bullet and this is where blunders
happening at 495 tonight it these are
the kind of positions I have ferruginous
been waiting to get rook up in a
scramble Knight g5 try to get the try to
get the pieces off the board watch out
for Texas okay moves rook yeah good you
had to move that yeah but this is what
foucha wants to be this is erroneous
first true test right where Ferruccio
has pushed him at a time scream yeah and
this is the second last game of this
time segment 95 check ooh but then she 3
and h5 Falls nice King moves he's got g3
and he loose on time because of it oh my
gosh victory a huge victory for firoozeh
brings it to within six games we have
one more game and Aronian taking a call
saying I can't talk to you right now mom
what are you doing I'm playing chess on
Twitch actually wait a second Oh whee oh
he's calling me hey LaVon hey dude you
got to focus okay thanks bye handle that
everybody don't you worry okay the next
game will begin here in just a moment
while we're waiting for that let me show
everybody why this one was was an end
and in a loss on time okay I'll bring up
the analysis board to show you JRM says
one ages he's calling his clock and
asking for more time classic the point
was no matter where the King moves g3 is
coming next and h5 falls so that fact
had him lose on time and with it
firoozeh gets a much much needed victory
we have the last game of the three
minute portion starting assuming that we
don't see any quick losses friesan the
chat there what's he throwing at I don't
think he was a happy that the game
didn't start immediately that's what it
seemed like okay well sometimes that
happens that happens but I think that
firoozeh looking to make a comeback once
as much time as possible so we'd like to
fire we like the fire for sure he didn't
start the fire I I'm gonna put it out
okay just wanna make sure you knew his
always burning there's nine thousand for
this thanks for being here
welcome to the big
as they call it the speed chess
championship on chess calm twitch.tv
slash chess wherever you may be thanks
for making us a part of your day that's
something that I hear them say in the
radio a lot well LaVon already is making
this a great chest day because he's up
11 to 5 he's had some amazing games that
end game that I called one of the best
games in speeches champion history yep
and you're right there's some reasons
you must did back it up yeah this is a
phenomenal game and right now with the
white pieces he's doing what he's done
all day take up space make versions life
difficult and know where to get counter
play and you just look at these Knights
on f6 and e7 and usually the question
you ask yourself is where do they belong
what's my dream square and I don't see
one right now for either these Knights
it's not like White's Bishop on c3 is
that great but if I can protect a four
and play for d4 just blast open the
diagonal for my bishop that goes to show
the power of having a bishop when your
people does not have one
and so c5 is a way to just stop that
yeah I say put the kibosh on it
don't let you open the position for the
bishop shoutout to Diamond member eilen
dower in the chest comm TV chat that's
an old school old school member what's
up Eric um Quinn d7 the d3 pawn now
falling you have to play a 93 with tempo
because just defending it okay that
gives time for more pressure but I guess
Knight B 3 is just met by b6 anyway and
the reason you really don't like playing
Brooke to eat the reason what your
knight on that Square you really want to
find 93 to d5 because that's why he did
that exactly the other route yep here
comes Knight B one O net B yeah everyone
works actually no it doesn't everyone
was met by Knight takes e4 let me show
it let me show it night b1 Knight takes
e4 there's a pin down the d5 if you take
what the rook f5 comes in and that's a
problem that's a pin to the King yep Wow
okay well LaVon back up on the clock
where he wants to be here comes that
night though
nice c3 to d5 yep just throw that pony
in there wants to bring the knight yet
trying to bring the knight in and gosh
the knight wants to come to d5 this
Knight wants to help for the
Hakan age 3 and everyone's happy yeah
yeah so I mean what is black gonna do
where's the counterplay
you attacked Age 3 it's protecting now
right then what why do you ask me such
tough questions I I wasn't ID 5 at f/4 I
want to play white hear you play black
but F 5 F 4 is clearly a good one
LaVon is bouncing around there panchak
leave them alone yeah dorable little dog
we want to see Pancho yeah we do s5 del
que you were asking where the plane is
coming that's counterplay and if you can
switch things back to the F file you've
got a weakness on f-22 a check how does
it actually I was gonna deal with this
because you didn't want to take on a
five that lessens your clamp on the d5
square so that now if you put a 95 black
and challenge that night there and try
to kick it out but yeah Queen on f1 okay
where's the e4 I like that move though
over protect you're trying to get rid of
blacks probably best attacker here and
if the trade happens the bishop still
has a target on e5 so you can take back
with either rook or pawn I actually kind
of like taking with the rode nt3 no
you're gonna take and take up two and
then take B - I don't know how I was
excited let's show it on the analysis
board to the Batcave we shall stay Luke
takes d3 Queen takes d3 Queen takes up
to Chuck and taking here wins two pawns
and a bishop for the exchange that would
have been interesting yeah especially
with the open King and the fact that you
finished the line with the tempo that
wasn't seen by either player that's
Grand Master Robert Hess dropping the
tactics you know sacrificing other
people's pieces was your nickname in
high school
very good one sacrifices other people's
pieces Bob definitely not so but the d3
part is a weakness of rook d7 you know
Queen of three first maybe then you got
a guard it
if White has time you just want to
coordinate some sort of defense of f2
and to get e5 now Queen e2 did you trade
Queens off does make regular sense get
the Queen out or head to the endgame can
you take you five now huh it's a pawn
right
they just ripped a d8 you can also play
brook III with tempo then double on the
e-file it's true very true I guess but
he's got to be calculating whether he
can take you five while he breathes
reason why was a wake up to d8 oh you
know he wants he wants Brooke she for
next and if the knight moves he has
Bishop takes h6
let's hope King age seven that was a
weird okay if that didn't work what was
the point of putting the bishop here
you're asking the wrong person
actually I have no idea now white is
very stuck c4 that's what's coming it's
dynamite
no can I retire now yep please but d4
buddy Wyatt c4 d 4 for white and boom
goes the dynamite pretty good there's D
for D for right back at you right
opening up c4 for explosive measures
against the black King bones continue
you're testing me little Bunch
actually it's not a joke take c4 with
check double on the D file yes pawns
gonna fall 95 is coming oh that's a fork
that's a big problem actually so what
you do here
rook be trying to cover the F games here
comes 95 anyway and then 3 3 he's coming
loose check 13 seconds this is turned
around it could we be headed a bullet
with two wins in a row for firoozeh
I think we are that's gonna be only a 5
game lead now you said it needed to be 4
he's putting himself within range and
bullet that's what he's trying to do
here ok so it takes h4 nice move here
comes f4 take d3 you have a queen takes
h4 with check the 24 check and some sort
of window everything's legal jiggle when
the rook is Queenie 4 check right away
wins it ah
Queen 4 check but that work at 353
you're right ok he's holding a queen for
check now is coming doesn't gonna be
enough yep and he resides and we have a
match ladies and gentlemen I know what
you're thinking Dan don't try to sell us
false prophet here it's a 5 game lead
for Levon Aronian but you're about to
see all the residue furro sure one of
the best
bullet players on the planet take on 30
minutes of the fastest segment
with his chance to make a comeback 9,000
viewers are here all of you will be here
when we get back because I'm watching
you we'll be we'll be back in just a few
moments
[Music]
a premium membership at chess calm will
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50 thousand
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you played turning every game into
a chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level
while the Vaughan Aronian may have just
ended the to blitz portions of the
speech Chess Championship match one
point higher actually than Hikaru
Nakamura now in blitz ratings on chess
calm the question is will the light come
on
for Olly Reza in the bullet portion I
was waiting for you to turn that light
on and I think that it absolutely will
but you know a lot of people here are
used to seeing all your fruit alley for
sure I'll give him an ollie fo sure his
name ali riza firoozeh dominate on chess
calm in bullet but there is that one
second increment so after every single
move Levon Aronian will gain a second on
the clock if he moves instantly and thus
I think that his chances of maintaining
his lead are quite huge well he's got
five points to just sort of keep the
comeback from happening he's a favorite
and bullet according to the smarter
chess predictions but you and I both
were were pretty questioning of that
right heading into this match here we
were looking at that a6 for potential
lead for Levon Aronian as far as
predictions go have me wanting to put
smarter chess as he's active and chat in
check here so what do we even think
about that yeah I just think that though
I mean it's a rating thing right
Levon Aronian is the high rated player
in classical he is a high rating in feed
a blitz but the issue is that Ali Riza
doesn't have that many terms plain in
terms of regular a blitz event so it
might be but it's a rating is low
relatively speaking Levon Aronian is a
beast but
Razors proved in the last world bliss
championship that he is an absolute
force in that time patrol yeah he'll
have a chance to do it today obviously
he's ranked 11th by those standards as
you said the the algorithm that all the
different places we look to kind of see
how we predict these players to perform
but I think that the gloves are coming
off here all the talk will not matter
here in just a few moments we're gonna
find out I think pretty quickly whether
Ollie Reza can can make make some
strides make it give us give us a
comeback or or whether the one second in
command will help the person maintain
his lead that being Levon Aronian so
games are about to leave to begin here I
believe so bullet will commence shortly
and we're gonna we're gonna have liftoff
here I'm putting a lot on this first
game here yeah because a tone setter
because I think it's just
psychologically emotionally - it's it's
gonna be a big question for Levon right
if he loses that first game yep
does that become a landslide and it
would be his third straight loss because
he lost the final two games of the
three-minute portion there and how IRISA
actually tied in the three plus one time
segments alright right now with the
white pieces I'll erase it going for the
Spanish yeah and well okay we'll see how
this takes off because I think with its
familiarity in these openings he'll be
okay I'll be able to speed through the
opening stages yep but if there is I can
get an advantage in the clock that will
be huge
he's got three seconds on the clock
right now a minute in one seconds he has
more time than he started with again
remind everybody that's because you get
a 1 second added to your back to your
total time with every move that is what
the 1+1 language means for chess and the
opening itself not bad for black though
right I mean this looks pretty good for
Levon centralized Queen opened e-file to
hit a target well coordinated and now
because of that we already see the time
advantage shifting the other way here
why can't I be for a forest still our
opportunity to expand for sure right and
he plays this way with Bishop III may
put the night on c5 right now and queen
c8 then Bishop III check now they put f5
is a very risky move
yeah f5 is the kind of double edged move
that you gotta be really
be careful about f5 f4 is he gonna try
to bring the bishop into the diagonal
this is uh gonna be tough
yeah looks a little strange honestly
because now move like Queen f3 or what
about Queen f7 threatening Bishop h5 and
try to induce f3 right I wanted to Queen
f3 so I could spy on your knight and c6
Queen honest but a4 makes a lot of sense
you can follow b4 now he's just gaining
space in the Queen side whoa that's a
pawn sack time pretty close to equal
though
LaVon with a small edge the increment
it's just gonna be the real the real
teller here because so many of us know
what all the res is capable of when the
time is goin off the clock but with the
1 second increment yeah I kind of move a
5 I'm not sure if it actually pans out
but I move like a 5 there is the follow
up with Bishop to a for pinning the
knight on c6 rook b5 is an option but
then you could take on before us and now
he traps that Bishop and I like this I
like this for block up 5 seconds on the
clock as well yeah 85 is falling things
are definitely taking a turn for the
worse for other is a 4 here and it's
hard to even change the structure here
because black is controlling more more
pressure over every center square both
d4 and e4 well d4 actually is a good
move right now
could have been I thought so but maybe
because of the back ring tactics I see
yeah okay and after that b3 pawn but if
but if Black gets the rook to d8 the d3
pawn will fall that's true but you 5 is
then hanging 5 seconds 4 seconds hey
bishop before got to play quickly Queens
now he's gonna lose gonna lose d3 what's
he going for here ok he's gone some sort
of trade of d3 for e5 but he ones a
problem in the end yeah this is just yet
falling apart here the wheels are coming
off Knight takes e4 about to be played
yeah Brooke you force that's how ok so
he backs up instead so no so still
almost in the game but no with 15
seconds here comes F 365 you have an f3
is coming and the white king is gonna be
blown open yeah I move over before it's
really nice yeah and the Queen prepared
to switch over to this side of the board
yep super dangerous Queen takes h3
threatens rook she for that check is but
a spite here comes rook c4 and it's over
oh okay you can trade and play Queen of
three double attacks Oh rook g3 and one
time he won a time no he resigned he
resign he resigned but what Oh cuz after
takes takes the rajendra oh my god I
thought he was flagging him that's why
we both yeah let's uh cuz that's just a
quick resignation yeah that was such a
quick resignation rook g3 was played
because the Brooklyn Fault will show it
real quick on the analysis board because
if it shocked both me and Robert I'm
gonna guess that everyone else when rook
g3 was played and all here as a loss we
assumed it was one of those getting your
opponent to flag moves but actually it's
a very good move because no matter where
the king goes here the Queen will go to
f3 with check pick up the Brooke and
black is just dominating at the Queen
ending up more pawns than we can count
so there you have it okay that is indeed
why Levon Aronian strikes first now you
said Robert the first game in the bullet
portion would be huge Levon Aronian wins
stretches the lead back to six games and
I think 11,500 people can kind of see
the writing on the wall here for the
young man from Iran it's now or never
mathematically time to start winning
chess games that no one did live on win
that game it took four minutes off the
timers yeah not that much time remaining
for version he needs to win all the
remaining games like like that's like a
saying in order to win games you got to
play better and faster than your
opponent needs to start winning a lot of
games here to come back
f4 so just take on Poisson probably put
your look at the English opening LaVon
is stuck with we definitely got to ask
him about this in the interviews it's
worked really well for him g4g next song
this is you can't take on g4 cuz it's
made on g7 everyone and no matter where
the bishop goes the pawn goes to g5
enforces the night away all you res is
hand is forced to sacrifice a piece and
Levon Aronian
flexing just forget to protect beggin if
the checkmate everything's defended
showing that the bullet portion
ollie resume be known right but Levon
Aronian is performing very well right
now even night h4 here for my rook g1 is
a good move I love it yeah nice was
actually quite a good move
if night h4 Knight takes rook to g1 the
Queen goes to h6 and then you play Queen
takes f6 and everything is pinned on the
G file yep he chooses this route but
okay rook g1 now it's also very good
there it is
trying to overprotect f6 but white is
just up a piece
Purusha frustrated given a smile of just
hey this guy's pretty good he's finding
all the right moves in all the right
places
Thank You OneRepublic yeah that was good
don't miss f7 nope he's got a defendant
okay this game in the back ranked first
otherwise Queen h2 or queen d1 would
deliver the check is good oh wait Oh
what do you want
look do you one rook diva buzz rook g1
always okay rook d1 King G - Queen e2
was made that's why we freak we're
freaking out freaking to freak out but
no it's nothing rook g1 White is still
in control here and in fact okay very
nice Bishop takes f6 fall just look at
him he's just he's playing with his food
right now I thought his mom taught him
better he's getting greedy over there
takes there's gonna be checks but not
gonna be enough to pick back the piece
yeah it's a drone wait Queen h3 yeah
down upon okay he's gonna play King h3
in Queen h4 what I think use your free
move Queen d1 got it thinking it was a
check so wait a second he's come back
here he won the night not not the best
technique for Aronian but one of the
things that's really bad is the amount
of time that's going off the clock here
we're only 22 minutes remain in the
match and he's out to pawns now okay
I'll get a to pawn he's down a pawn in a
queen ending we're LaVon has nine point
eight seconds now over ten he's moved
too quickly LaVon has no problem milking
this thing Yeah right
get as much time off the total clock as
you can remember everybody that's what
makes the speech his championship a
little different more gamesmanship it's
actually really bad news because he's
gonna play this out for another 50 moves
hey nothing wrong with that right
you know just bad news for ali riza
because there's no forcing draw it at
this point
so he's in a waste time as I'm wasting
time he is apple pie epsilon e is
everybody my twin was kiddin if he takes
another two minutes off the clock and
wins that would be the worst thing
possible while he continues to dance his
King around four checks let's remind
everybody that we have a doubleheader
today meaning right after this match
regardless of what you're seeing right
now we will be joined by two very very
strong chess players from Russia
Vladislav Artemyev versus alexander
Grichuk it's it's anybody's pick them
and this one Robert and I have disagreed
on who we actually think the favorite is
in this match we're not gonna tell you
who that is until that match begins but
stick around because we have eight hours
of chess today and after this match we
have our next PGA Championship right
away yeah it's gonna be a long day but
it's gonna be a fun day and we already
have had a lot of fun in this match
between Aronian and firoozeh but right
now look at lafon right now ferocious
not having any fun no it's not fun when
your opponent is just yeah kind of like
his mom didn't eat he's playing with his
food here it's just poke and prod and
torturing and match strategy would
suggest that it's a good idea to get as
much time off the clock as he can look
at that wood Queen deform Oh takes away
all the checks what a nice move now the
Kings back in 97 can be 7 or d6 no
checks I almost saw King G 7
there's no checks of all 7 there was
Queen a3 check but now a Queen d6 oh my
gosh that would have been nasty yep
everyone if the King gets to e7 here
comes we have 6 here he goes he's gonna
see it t7 I missed it again
Queen c6 okay he's feeling he can get
the Queen he can get the King here g7
yet here comes b7 all heroes is gonna
lose and with it so much time just came
off the clock
that was speeches championship
experience there from Levon Aronian his
technique has been great I mean this has
been I know that he was the favorite in
the match yeah but this has been some of
the best speech s we've ever seen the
Bond play on our site and he has played
in all three years of the speech s
championship he's plating the bullet
chess championship this has been some
very high-quality yeah there was
obviously blunders in that game where he
was completely winning and even that
game he didn't lose you know
in that last game like oh yeah he was up
a piece things are tricky but his
endgame technique when he was up that
pawn he was just pushing his king
forward yeah he allowed some checks
he went f5 on e4 cemented the black
pawns and just what a nice Queen ending
there yeah I think smarter chest jokes
aside we love Matt it's a fun debate we
have shut up to Grand Master Indian lad
playing guess the move on chest on hump
by the way and now even winning not even
winning Horace Slughorn Harry Potter
characters always steal my thunder the
professes back
the professor's back but no a smarter
chess I agree I think Levon Aronian has
gotten better with every speech Chess
Championship match for those of you who
know the full history and the first ever
event we did he lost Alexander Grisham
in a thriller by the way that was a
thrilling match and he's gotten better
every year since then and and you know
so really impressive to see right now
putting on a show for us with a
seven-game lead over all the rows of
Arusha yep just playing excellent chess
he's having a lot of fun doing it and
well you know gonna hear his thoughts
afterwards but you know the Frisia fans
out there it's just a tough matchup for
me yeah well I mean Levon Aronian is the
stronger player and we talked about that
in these formats and I think making the
70/30 prediction look a little bit
smarter than it did previously
but we've you know you know I've talked
about it we both thought that Levon was
the favorite I know hey kar who said
that Perugia was the favorite I think
that's what he said yesterday or that
might be more online chess than other
top grandmasters have speaking for her
Carlos biased there because I think he's
definitely thrown down against Perugia
yeah but it's always forgotten how much
the increment changes the game this is
serious chess chess moves matter this is
not just flagging yeah you know and I
think it shows that the stronger players
are able to keep up even in time
scrambles so Aronian right now down on
the clock for the first time really
since we've been in the bullet portion
yeah that's been a long time since we've
seen that yep I tried a favor to move
his Queen because queen b2 is in mine
Bishop D for winning the 95 so it's kind
of an awkward spot it was Queen e2 wow
there are a lot of I'm looking at
there's so many pieces on the e-file
Queen takes e8 there's Queen takes new
one
Rotech see to those rook takes exactly
so whatever you do I'll do to what a
move right there 93 yep
and oh another pin too many pins he's
gonna sack the Queen for two rooks
but watch out these two Brooks and a
knight are gonna have dangerous things
in store for the King out of that decent
pawn that's about a d6 who's better
right I don't know i mean i think that
the d6 pawn should be good for firoozeh
will he get his first bullet win and 93
can come at any moment here he does it
but Bishop e6 nice move kid there's rook
c1 that was a bounce Levon he didn't
even show to you both yeah like rook c7
it was like oops but it wasn't even my
uber just like he's watching a movie and
he's so enthralled right he hasn't
changed his face once something
like a small plot twist yeah we didn't
see that guy the movies still going
shadow to the bits and the subs all of
you viewers and the premium members of
chess calm thank you for being here
seriously we do it for you and we
appreciate you tuning in all right we've
got another English this time Kings
Indian defense kind of fee and keto
transposition but once again an edge for
white Levon Aronian sticking with
openings that he feels he can flex his
transpositional experience yeah it seems
very nice for what you've more space
your Bishamon g2 has been ambition 27
you can play for efore if you'd like you
didn't have to but you can choose to and
just expand the quinta for a similar
idea you're getting your Queen to more
advanced square and as before here's met
by a three just to separate the a2 pond
from the b4 pond oh you chose not to
well right now you've got the so temple
in the night you can play a three if
you're white if you want to stop it I'm
not sure that a three is that effective
I guess the bishop can sit Wow b5 I
guess b5 and d6 a problem knight on c3
there's also problems
there's also 94 coming in if there
should be five Queen h6 followed by
Knight g5 delicate I wanted it you want
it all you're getting superb but that
was getting a little too frisky there I
enjoyed it this is f4 an idea for white
take that bet for kick the bishop and d6
falls because of that for Russia has to
attack the knight yep and now where does
that night go goes to g5 anyway
alright safe there efore and now another
threat for a white just to hit that
Bishan 105 yeah there's also c5 now that
there's a tempo to be gained it's true
and he goes for it don't like take and
then play Knight c4 yeah cuz the 9 g5 is
also hanging yeah this would overwhelm
the Queen if you take C for the g5 9
hangs there it is okay but there's so
many weird things going on here if you
takes you 5 do I have f4 oh wow a three
sing
and H free singing yeah was Bishop ixh
people oh my gosh Bishop takes h3 but
I've been even better prefer OSHA but he
just wanted to gobble up the material
he's gonna take this one Bishop e6 and
taken a two okay
I agree good enough alright yeah I think
Bishop takes a she was better but looks
like blacks should be able to take how
you like them apples on the a file here
comes a new queen yeah a three queen bee
- and yell to get word yep yep just
don't blundering a bishop is g6 tough
but so one thing you have King up - yeah
everything's falling yeah Livan not
gonna resign no reason to write more
time coming off the clock with only 14
minutes remaining at this point
Aronian is in in good shape to move on
to the second round the corner for
quarterfinals as it would be for the
2019 SP Chess Championship despite
losing that game he still has a five
game lead not mathematically over okay
so we shouldn't call it yet we've seen
crazier things i honest think it was a
mistake from the resign ya get more time
off the clock he could have taken
another 30 45 seconds easily yeah just
play right just just make moves you're
gonna lose anyway right that's the thing
and people always ask this question
those who are not familiar with chests
say why do people give up why they
resign and in most cases the result is
without a doubt you know you're gonna
lose so you give up and he was going to
lose no matter what but in this
particular instance with a timer
counting down you
should always play it out when you have
a lead on the scoreboard no totally fair
and I think the only thing that he would
argue against that is if he
psychologically feels in such a good
place he's just playing just right now
he doesn't want to think about the
gamesmanship just wants to continue to
do what he's done most of the day I'll
play his young opponent right I think
there is some to be said for that right
you're keeping yourself focused in the
moment psychologically but but you're
totally right and getting more time off
the clock it's just like an insurance
policy to make sure you're gonna win
right yep here comes h4 h5 yeah firoozeh
wins another game here it's four games
with probably about ten minutes left
yes no shot not over yo is g4 coming I
want it if he does it I'm gonna throw
the emote give me the emote let me throw
the emote feel you kind of have to what
what are you f5 was the response oh my
gosh oh my gosh yeah we have a bunch of
gifted subs everybody's happy everyone
supported chests it's happening g4g
floor this is a crazy position
I thought doesn't take on h5 because you
couldn't take enough three as Queen
takes g6 check the Queen is stuck
protecting the g6 square Wow
I don't even know what time is ticking
who who's gonna get an attack here both
sides 94f to g6 we're gonna Knight d4
here like d4 Knight e5 you shut your
mouth when you're talking to just to me
I'm just kidding you keep talking yeah
94 looks good a queen of tune if she was
Czech but then Queens check what in the
world
queen of two would have taken h4
woodchuck two though what was happening
no you can take your can't go to h3 oh I
was thinking one king h1 sorry okay yeah
now you got a guard g6 in our life but
then the discovery on the fisherman d4
as well as well h5 it's five seconds for
LaVon six weeks for firoozeh take that
pond this is how the comeback happens if
Ferrucci gets another victory here uh-oh
whoa laughing in the face of the
discovered check because you can dreams
are made of what a move he's just
laughing at the checks he's gotta play
rook d7 to guard the mate and now how do
you continue this bishop 'if
41:47 yeah somewhere seven check is
coming but king h1 yeah but oh my gosh
Bishop b5 check is if King f1 Queen
takes e4 that's what he didn't see what
what does Ponting z4 know the poem is
pinned of king of what there's a king h1
okay I was saying if king of what oh
yeah made him look up seven well he was
getting made it anyway ah 55 checklist
yeah you scared me so many times
me as a king h1 and you went King f1 I
was talking about King F wanted provide
an instructive point we have 12,500
euros maybe about to witness the
greatest comeback in speeches
championship history if you're just
joining us at one point the lead was
eight games yeah for Levon Aronian it is
now four games with ten minutes left
pretty tough pretty tough mathematically
cuz the time continues to tick yep but
if we were ever gonna see a matchup
where we know we have an amazing bullet
player all heroes of Arusha right versus
a stronger player emotional things
happen kilt is real right yep and other
is at some point you need to play
instantly because you're talking about
the time situation ten minutes left in
the match yep with the one second
increment you get a 60 move game right
that's adding a couple minutes to the
clock so you really have to move
instantly if you're firoozeh
and you have to what you also have to
keep winning yeah right so the problem I
mean he if he needs to take his time to
find the best moves he has to do that
too right a single loss it's over
yep right a draw with a couple minutes
off it's almost the same thing right so
at this point it's win or go home quite
literally and I feel he's a pretty low
scoring match so our 22 games put a
bunch of long games I don't know we've
done a lot of SCC matches usually we can
say the average SEC match is about 28
games okay
so it's not that we're six games off
yeah but there's still a couple more to
be played yeah I think why never really
around 25
I don't by the way I just totally made
up that stat if someone wants to confirm
that the average games are about 28 but
I've done a lot of these and I think
that's right you have to but you know H
for the world what is how you don't h2o
but you can't move the night that's a
dark square problem JC wrote a song
about that look at that yeah but you
know king h7 rook g8 and then movie
night I guess
uh-huh takes a while
but it's worth it also you can whoa whoa
night if three I love it he's gonna take
with the rook and take g3 and you love
it that's how you do it that's the
practical chess
turning around he wants efore next but
the Queen h4 okay it's not hanging I
like before I like you for oh but look
at the ferocious playing well yep he's
playing well here comes Queen th 1462
Queen takes you to there it is found it
there it is that is a huge tactic
because after eight minutes remain if he
wins this game oh my gosh
and you have to just play on I think if
you are LaVon keep playing and find
yourself right you know right for
calling him up for resigning that game a
few games ago that we should never sign
that would be nuts one second he's
losing on time he had no moves so it's
just under eight minutes just under
eight minutes with a three game lead for
Levon Aronian
yep the tilt is real right now for the
Armenian who again if you're just
joining us at one point had an eight
game lead in this match that is down to
three as far as the bullet chest goes we
have a two-game advantage right now for
the young 16 year old from Iran you can
see the scoreboards there right beneath
the player cams if you're wondering you
can also see the average matches 28.1
game if you're wondering whether this is
winnable it is young Christopher Duda
was down two games against Sasha Grichuk
last year with six minutes to go yep and
he won he won all the games that
remained and they didn't even need
overtime he won is the match expired at
some point here will remind you of what
happens if we go to overtime but for now
let's let's stay focused until until we
we can talk about that but overtime is a
thing and we do have some information to
share with you on that if it happens but
this is not I don't think is the
position that other isn't one and after
several straight victories he's in this
position where you have to really work
to win a position like this you know as
black you're covering when I started Mia
and she Tuesday stopped it but you have
these isolated pawns a two and see if
they're in the queenside that you have
to keep an eye on for white and black
has no real weaknesses and we have the
tiebreak procedure up yep on screen for
everyone who is
wondering I don't think it's going to
happen I still think that LaVon is
taking this match but if this game
quickly game goes for white yeah and
there you have it if a match is tied
after regulation which means the time
runs out like an NBA game or a lot of
other sports
we do have overtime which is a four game
mini match of 1+1 so the fastest time
control continues to be where they have
to duke it out if we do not have a
winner there we will go to Armageddon
which is a single game with time
advantage for white but draw odds for
black meaning a split peaceful game
means black will still win so there you
have it right there that is the tiebreak
format and will we have it who knows
we've had it before g5 now that's a move
that you'd totally seen a classical game
anytime I see that move in a bullet game
I'm scared I want to take it back yeah
because when your King gets weak you
guys start anything scared you get
emotionally not playing objective chest
then you're in trouble but right now
Livan feeling very well in this game and
he's taking up a lot of time because
when I moved 27 so we've added a taken
away down the minute from the match
timer a 5 a 5 would have moved but I
think b5 is the response and now c4 is a
square too many explosives to happen
here boom goes the dynamite insert
ridiculous pop-culture joke I paid my
dues
you remember boom goes the dynamite yeah
13 thousand people do I bet to this a
good move c4 look at the time 7 seconds
all the reason playing fast there's a 95
hanging if you move your Queen off who's
better the Knights hanging oh my god 68
Queen Dixie 5 wins apiece yes wondered
he's upset play play LaVon I don't was I
won no oh my gosh no you need to play
that on he's not protecting his lead in
the match format and we have a two-game
advance he needs to play on he needs to
play on and take time off the clock he's
forgetting the match strategy I know
that staff is there but I want to remind
them I'm sure we are letting the players
know of how much time remains officially
on the game clock
they are usually aware and we always
suggest to them in pre match pep talks
or let's say format talks to keep their
own timer so that they're aware but but
yeah the players are being informed we
have a carrier
this is just nuts I just can't believe
you're silent right now he's resigning
he's not playing it out I mean he could
take another 30 seconds off each of
these losses and we'd be talking about
we'd be talking about you know a good
good effort young man but not enough
time to come back so I know it's legit
it could happen
like I'm gonna put queen c6 keep the
bind going okay this is this is better
for white nail but the double-edged
position that black needs to play
forgive the - Bishop for sure if you
ever play f5 which is an aggressive
movement if the g5 square for the
diagonally for is a very good move and
you want your solution to the choir
right now I love it I love it I love it
exciting stuff here comes f5 for White
Queen f3 maybe I think rhyme and then 94
yeah I like Queen f3 you don't want to
commit yes slow take it slow slow jam it
slow jam at Jamie Foxx bringing the
night in but then Bishop e7 c-4 is
coming like this is good play for black
I'm not saying that white money of time
money of time
f5 so he's giving him fo to f6 I think
you should take with the Queen on f5
yeah just tried to get the ladies off
cuz if you take with the pawn lavon's
not taking he's gonna try to get an
attack I think he's still gonna take you
think so yeah he doesn't try to trade
off some pieces because okay what black
compensation are plays go c4 now go 94
oh but then you take on a5 yeah that was
tricky Wow
wait take on g6 wait Wayne h3 g6 go -
why do you take on g6 oh he's just gonna
win e7 again he is not calculating well
what was that Levon just misses a chance
to win if you had taken g6 Queen f3 in
the end everybody after trade trade
black loses the bishop on e7 with just a
winnable and if he took with the F on
this Queen d5 check he missed that
probably and right now he's gonna trade
Queens
take a c5 is hangs who should be sent f6
and you take so he's still better but he
just missed a win yeah now you should
take a 97th coming watch out all 97 this
could be it this could be the match
right here if Levon wins this game
mathematically ali reza will be down to
much to come back so do I play 94 and
just allow your be 394 is the practical
thing to do to just sit on the clock the
annoying thing is that the C 1 square is
covered so if I get rook c8 in and you
can't compete yes life is still
the game here comes rook c8 now if 94
there's room I like before the huge move
but if you have rookie to see file close
if you have rookie to there's some
bishops e1 stuff you have to be very
careful yet the King should have come up
though Kings coming up 94 check you
can't take it by g5
ok 5 seconds 4 seconds here comes the
King one minute remains if Olly Rosa
wins the CD 5 Brooke if one check thrown
in the Czech probably yeah that's why we
check I don't want the King all the way
up in my face but if all you Reza wins
this game there will be enough winning
f4 oh my gosh oh my gosh absolutely
crazy what's about to happen here is he
winning though f2 Brooke if rook
somewhere then b6 b7 knowing is a
must-win situation for doesn't stop oh
my gosh Rick oh my god Rick boy ali reza
silly rabbit tricks are for kids
oh my gosh here comes two pawns to
connected or better than none but
actually a minute remains on the total
game plot but if all he residents this
neptune the ticket agent who takes h3 it
takes f3 and every except for huge ollie
resident may have just lost the match
with that blender oh my gosh besa oh
it's over
t7 b8 queen is coming it's over I don't
know yet there's still enough time Neji
why don't you check check Brookes exact
to weaken takes T 4 and Livan one eye
and head shaved off back with that draw
and firuze is laughing Raja is
officially eliminated because with 30
seconds left though this game counts and
every game has a little bit of prize
money on the line the comeback is over
he looks up what a great performance
let's remind everybody of the prizes for
those who don't watch the speeches
championship as much as they now will
that was drama not only does the winner
win
the majority of the cash but remember
the rest of the money is split by win
percentage so it's one of the things we
really like about the format because it
means that even this game probably
counts for about 40 bucks okay you know
a little bit of cash right take the lady
out but either way the match is
officially over because with a two-game
lead LaVon could lose this game and
still move on to the quarterfinals and
Krantz an eraser who made us really
close but what did I say earlier
for game deficit heading into the bullet
with Olli raisin needed right but it's
five games just short yeah it was five
your profit today give me some of that
baby just so you know we're just getting
started right after this match we have
another speech as championship affair
Vladislav Artemyev of russia will take
on alexandra crook we will have a very
very short break and we have another
speech Chess Championship match coming
right up after this so don't go anywhere
plenty of chess ahead this is our
first-ever doubleheader for the SCC
and I don't think we could have started
off with anything better I mean I'm just
mesmerized by the play here all there
isn't in the bullet has been great yep
and it's easy to forget because of how
long ago it seems that Levon totally
dominated the 5-minute yeah look at the
7 to 2 school wasn't just the score it
was the way he played yeah he was great
yep and you know all credit still on for
winning this match but Alireza you know
he's young he's 16 years old just if he
got some more experience if he gets a
little bit more opening knowledge that
comes with experience not right I'm not
trying to criticize his opening he's
actually obviously an amazing opening
player he just when you get the more
experience you can play different things
feel more comfortable in different
variations and once he gets that I mean
the guy's gonna be an absolute just
monster in these SE C's for years to
come absolutely crazy stuff the speech
Chess Championship rolls on here
remember again like I said another match
coming up right after this and we will
have interviews first of course we'll
talk to the players both of them in
terms of what their match strategy was
how they felt about different critical
moments and get their insights so a lot
of fun when we hear from the players and
get their thoughts
here comes d5 Queen 87 called it I think
I think faroush is gonna win with a
crazy attack and finish just one game
short yeah d 5 moves really nice Queens
coming to a 7 as you pointed out to 8
for checkmate if you go King to be 8 you
don't do it it's over oh the King
running he's surviving I take c5 is
great and I think if there's Knight b6
and then I was root 65 right away
that should be enough so is there any
other move that
prolong this cuz verse 65 Bishop d6 and
just take on e5 and then the King runs
but whites I would sack the Queen sack
the Queen on e5 Oh actually yeah look at
the kingdom's in a weird net okay he did
it in a different way I don't like that
one as much I don't think but plenty of
play thanks to it the pawn f3 the King
on h1 is stuck there wait here's one but
no now you hang the rook and it's and we
have we have the final game being a
victory for all the press of Russia
which means he only loses this match by
one point when it's all said and done
thirteen and a half to 12 and a half
will be is the final score about to be
updated wowzers we are gonna have
interviews in just a moment when we
return we will hear from both the winner
Levon Aronian - loser ali reza firoozeh
more speeches championship we'll be
right back
[Music]
eight of the most elite chess960 players
on the planet are set to clash in the
feed a world fish a random Chess
Championship quarterfinals
beginning October 4th and ending October
6th played exclusively on chess calm
it's a game where creativity is king and
memorization is impossible and only one
player will earn the right to call
themselves the king of Fischer random
Vladimir Pharaoh say Oh
ali reza perugia wesley so Fabiano
Caruana Peter Svidler yan de pomme the
Oishi fitted Gujarati and Hikaru
Nakamura these players will take center
stage as they attempt to outwit and
outclass each other in a chess variant
that many consider to be the game in its
purest form the feet a world fish a
random Chess Championship quarterfinals
will be an event like no other with over
350,000 dollars in prizes up for grabs
it is the biggest prize fund for any
event in online chess history will you
tune in to witness who moves on from the
quarterfinals to join Magnus Carlsen and
Oslo tune in on the first weekend of
October on chest comm TV and twitch.tv
slash chess
it's the feed a roll Fisher random Chess
Championship organized by June day s and
chess calm
and we are back now with the players
after what was one of the most exciting
chess matches let alone speed chess
matches we've ever ever had the pleasure
of commentating on LaVon you told us
just now as we were waiting off-camera
that you felt like you needed about a
five or six game lead headed into bullet
to just stave off what might come from
the young ollie Reza how nervous were
you there as he was mounting his
comeback pretty nervous because I didn't
see the score I didn't know how long we
have to play so the timer idea generally
does make sense but yeah Ollie Reza what
were your thoughts coming in as far as
how you looked at this match obviously
you know you're playing a very very
strong chess player one of the world's
elite but you know you're you're looking
for bullet what were your thoughts in
terms of your match strategy and what
did you think you needed to have the
score being headed into bullet I think I
played good in beliefs I won the first
game and second game I was just
completely winning with different self
could be five that's it to come be five
I'm a just lots of support I should just
resign I think but after that he just
played very very good and I don't know I
think after that was not easy to get a
better result
yeah and LaVon you seemed to really
enjoy these English positions was that
specific preparation for the match today
or was it just spur-of-the-moment
decision making well later 84 and then I
didn't like my usual well there was a
lot of variety to it though I mean you
were you were playing the English was
that just you kind of taking what ollie
Reza was trying against the English or
did it was there any strategy there that
that you felt like you were getting good
positions and so you stuck with it well
I think in the long match like this you
start trying the openings so I tried
before then I didn't like what I got
then I tried c4 and I like to like that
so
and then I stopped playing it so I guess
that's how you generally play the Blitz
long matches and weights you first try
to find your what your opponent doesn't
roll with only resident LaVon also said
off-camera as we were getting ready to
go live for the fans here that he
wonders now if maybe you had resigned
that long queen and pawn ending if maybe
you would have had more time on the
clock what did you ever have any
thoughts about that I know you were very
aware of the timer obviously you kind of
knew in the end right when LaVon held
that draw that you had run out of out of
opportunities so did you have any
gamesmanship or thoughts going in your
head about strategies in terms of maybe
resigning a game like that moving pieces
and maybe that was my mistake ya on the
flipside
LaVon with a huge lead there were some
positions you resigned which I was
saying you know you just play it out so
check me this essentially to waste more
time did I never go through your mind to
suffer a bad position for as long as
possible
you know I if you are doing such things
then you're being petty and despite the
fact that I am a terrible bullet player
well it comes because they don't have
any experience I hope well we were
wondering obviously the all of us on the
edge of our seats as time was taking
away and this became a closer management
overall of course in the blitz portion
you you know you uh you played very well
and and had the lead you needed Olly
Reza this was your first ever main
speech as championship obviously will be
will be very excited to have you back
but now that you've played in a couple
of these you playing the junior
speechless championship you played in
the main event any takeaways to share
what you've learned about the different
formats the different time controls how
to how to how to keep your head in the
game any thoughts to share about your
experience that you've had over these
last few months I think I didn't play no
games in Chatham this increment before
the match and I'm not playing normal
increments so that was my problem and
overall I think in portion I think I
should just play this out nervous
because first two games of today I just
played very bad and then I have no
chance then I played so good I think so
I think first first games first two
kings or three games of flint material I
think my last question may be our last
question will be then for you Levon
congratulations again you're moving on
right after this match we have vladislav
our Tim you have taken all Alexandra
crook you played Sasha before in this
format but as you look at those two guys
who are you rooting for who are you
rooting for to win and play you in the
quarterfinals well our leadership is my
generation there is some camaraderie
there but I don't know I never played
against Artemia so that could also be
exciting so I mean all I know I will
root for some good games okay and I have
one last question for you our eraser
tomorrow starts the Fischer random World
Championship quarterfinals how are you
feeling about the 960 event beginning
just tomorrow you could you could face
anybody you could face anyone from
Hikaru to yond upon Miyoshi to vladimir
Ferro say of any any favorite picks not
that we have any say-so over that but
just curious and everybody is tough
there something I should just blame like
good chess and you'll see well Avant I
know ponch
is waiting for a walk and you can you
show him on camera real quick so I can
say hi what language do panchak speak
Armenian English Russian all of the
above panchak panchak mostly i think
speaks twitter is for chicks watch the
meister follow on twitter at punch the
meister if you're looking for the best
follow on twitter there he is right
there
all right well Levon congratulations
Ollie Reza also congratulations a great
match an incredible few months here with
all these speeches champion matches we
thank you for for doing it and given all
of us a lot to cheer for and Levon best
of luck we will see you I guess in a few
weeks know that when our quarterfinals
begin but we'll see you then
thank you bye guys bye panchak alright
well we need it we need a ponch emote I
told the Vaughan if we can get him
streaming and he's always you know I
don't know if he can he can throw down
streaming he's too busy for that but you
know we gotta get ponch and emote so the
fans can spam it there it is Jeff hspace
got a I can't tell is that a cat job
that's what is that is that a what is
what is that a cat dog oh well but we do
have one match coming up artemyev irska
shook Aronian made his preference known
his good friend Alexander Grisha but
it's anyone's match on that one right
there you see it the 611 matchup two
Russians won one of the younger
generation the the new guard taking on
the old guard a former world blitz
champion that an Alexandra shook so a
lot is ahead here as we get set to take
another very quick break mainly because
we need the players to join us no real
Nova plans to be long so sorry for those
of you that are just anxious Robin and I
are gonna do our best to refresh
ourselves before we wrecked our selves
and we will be back probably in about
ten minutes the stream is going to stay
live so everyone take a snack but don't
close your browser and our Tim
universe's grishnak more speeches
championship action coming back when we
return